I rarely watch the event live.
Hello? Skanks. What's up? Hello live.
This is sort of hell. You were
recorded. Could you see boys?
Duggans avenue things got strange.
As soon as I said we're alive,
everybody's like, whoa. Oh Man.
We were having a great conference.
Now we're listening a little too high
right now. People are listening to what?
God Damn Mike Tyson weed and we really
were just having the most natural
conversation. Everyone was going back
and forth. Nothing. Yeah, Mike Tyson.
We were talking when you
went to the bathroom.
Mike Tyson says he smokes $40,000 of weed.
We also sells weed, so he just
charges it himself. A lot of money.
He gets hired as a supply
slip. $40,000 worth of weed.
I mean maybe like his whole crew.
You have to say this about himself.
There's no way a month.
How much is 40,000 I want to see what
it looks like in a room like, yeah,
am I buying that? It would be a pile
that you could fall into and take a nap.
Like you could definitely take like bean
bag chair and you could fly through the
air with confidence. So how much is,
I mean you're getting it in bulk,
so it's going to be probably like a
hundred dollars it's getting worse.
Even less than that. If you're
going to spend 40 grand,
they'll give you more than 40 grands
worth just to be like, here, man.
We smoked 10 tons of weed at
the ranch a month. Oh my God,
this is Britain said uh Eban.
Is that how you say his name?
Even Eben. Eben Britton.
So a 10 tons of weed is $40,000
that doesn't seem right,
does it? None of that seems
right. [inaudible] pounds
of weed. It's impossible.
He obviously could have easily been joking
and laughing while he said this too.
We're reading it in print, but he's
like, dude, we smoked 10 tons a month.
We talk. That's what I'm saying.
Sounds like something I would say
more than you trying possibly imagine
with the chef. Keep burning
and we brought in all the time.
We don't even believe I'm going
to throw out a wild number.
Forty million forty million,
40,000 someone should maybe
some journalists should do. Oh,
look up.
Do just make an image of this is what
$40,000 worth of weed looks like.
Yeah.
It's going to be more than even like Tyson
and his crew can smoke when they fill
this whole room. I think
it would. It'd be, yeah.
One of the like shipping crates is, is it?
There's a graph. Is it even possible
to smoke $40,000 a weed a month?
980 [inaudible] not that much, but
with a cro niner I think about it.
If you do a two grand blunts,
that's two blonds per eighth
essentially a little bit less.
This guy's got a broken down baby.
This guy really could just tell
you how much it is in bulk.
He's giving you 908th seems a little bit
lazy to even write 1800 blondes between
Mike Tyson's. Crew is not actually that
much for a month. It's not that much.
Now when I'm looking at the how
this guy saying it, he's saying it.
It's basically four blunts per
hour. That's totally possible.
If you've got a number of people with you.
I will never question Mike Tyson
again. This is it ever Amanda.
Not still not 10 tons. I
think we're being silly.
I think they were joking around. I bet a
lot of it they give away too. You know,
they might go through a personal
stash of that much weed.
I didn't know we have ranch, right?
Tyson's in the weed game son all in. Dude.
He was one of the most fascinating
guys that interview because I couldn't
believe I was really
talking to them. So like,
I can't believe that's really Mike
Tyson. Like there's smart people.
Like you talk to them like, oh, that's
really Mike Tyson. This is crazy.
It doesn't make sense
what he's been through in his life.
Yeah. You're like, and now he's here
knowing him as a kid when he was the
fucking man and you'd see him on the cover
of these magazines like kid dynamite
when he was 19 years old on sports
illustrated and just smashing everyone
in front of him and then all of a sudden
he's hanging with you. Yeah.
It's very strange. She's 10.
It's also just as a fall from grace and
then a resurgence and still weird for
surgeons too. Like nobody ever
saw him becoming like, you know,
cartoon character and like a fucking
Broadway actor and a one man show and now
we'd rancher. That's
[inaudible] who saw that?
Nobody said that was going to be Mike
Tyson's trajectory. I just hope it doesn't
started the tech, the uh,
the trajectory of when I found out who
he was when I was a kid and started
getting those bought like very shortly
after you saw it, a monster he was,
was that Robin Givens interview where he
just sat there like a doofus while she
was like gay beats up me and rapes
my mom and he's like, [inaudible]
[inaudible] just go on. Like when
these cameras go off, oh boy,
you better hope that thin if you
go to the phone for four days.
But wasn't there some talk
about them medicating him?
Wasn't that part of what was happening?
Like they were the Mama Rob
given to date him? Maybe.
I just remember him talking about him
in the documentary and he was just like,
he said he was just so, he
couldn't believe she was saying it,
so he was just like silent.
But if you watch it,
it seems like he's furious and just
trying to not say something angry.
Key to Mike Tyson is that he always
seemed like he was furious. Yeah,
and he even talked about it once. He
goes, I'm just mad. I'm mad at my dog.
I'm mad at everything, and that's when
he was at the top of the heat, man.
Fuck how? He's like this
peaceful, friendly guy.
He had to overcompensate for all that.
That's why he needs 40,000 childhood.
It was all therapy. Right. He had to
be, he has had like 20 therapists.
He beat up the first seven of them.
I mean, to be a great fighter,
you have to be able to look at yourself.
You have to be able to look
at your skills. You still,
it doesn't mean you still
can't make horrific mistakes,
but you have to be able
to look at yourself.
It's the only way you get any better.
Those the best fighters
have an understanding. Even
if they have ego problems,
they still have a pretty good
understanding of who they are and that's,
that can benefit you if you use it.
I'm sure he probably went through
therapy but he didn't necessarily,
he could probably have figured it out
on his own just cause he's a smart guy.
He's a smart guy that
grew up in a horrible,
horrible where the first love he had was
an old boxing trainer that turned him
into a murderer. Then that was the
first love that guy experienced.
His life was horrible man.
And from him being adopted by custom
motto when he was a little kid and having
extreme physical gifts as well.
It was this perfect storm did they said
when he was 13 he weighed 190 pounds.
Teddy Atlas used to bring him to boxing
the smoker events and they were like
Dang,
he's fucking 13 and they put him in
with a 16 year old cause nobody wants to
believe that a 13 year old could
be jacked like that when Jay would,
when Jason was 13 years old,
they were like two 20 it's true.
[inaudible] different kind of was
it a different build? He be okay.
I got them motherfuckers out
of your Goddamn tank. Yeah.
That's not a 13 year
old. You want to fight.
Also fun fact he is the reason Mike Tyson
solely is the reason why now if you're
on TV for even five minutes they start
scurrying about your tattoos being
covered or can you get a release for
the mall because when he came on a,
was it the hangover movie,
the company that did where the tattoo
artists that did his face tattoo suit for
like and I think one for
like millions of dollars.
How is that possible for doing the movie?
Because they used that purchase artwork
without them. Once you put a tattoo on.
Yeah. Nobody is your own, you know,
you claimed part ownership of that
Yeltsin that makes tattoo so much.
Gayer it just, you know, walk around
with some fucking dudes. Oh yeah,
this is fine. This is, I married in a
lesbian in Alaska. This is when I became,
I guess a a partners in life with
a guy in Montreal who spoke French.
Say how many tattoos did we
have in common? We are the same.
You guys have a bunch of 10. One, two,
three. Yeah, we have the day of suicide.
What did, what did, what do you guys
have here we go. Oh, we're doing that.
You guys get, what do you,
what's happening here?
There's a lot of people that can't
hear this. So what are these things?
This is notes half hearts. It
says Dave and Smith. Wow. Yeah.
So you are on their arm. Yeah. These
two would make you uncomfortable.
I did not consent to see much of a pussy
to get a tattoo. So we did it for him.
Ah, these are very cute. He's very
Jewish. That's real love, man.
You guys have to stay
friends for life. Now.
I know I was going to be out the
door and they got this tattoo.
No girls want to get married,
guys do that. Oh Bro, Bro,
I'm fucking [inaudible] Bro.
You got to do much. I tried to,
hey, you could have as many guys tattooed
on you. I don't care. I'm not jealous,
but I want my fucking name on your
leg, Bro. There was a Worldstar,
there's a wellstar video yesterday of a
guy catching a girl cheating in a hotel
and the other guy's like naked in the
hallway and she's like in her underwear
and the guy is just screaming at her.
There's a guy there and she just
fucking keeps going. And he's like,
I got my fucking your name tatted on me.
And she's doing all of that. I'm sorry.
Calmed down. I'm sorry.
And when she just decides that she
doesn't give a shit anymore, she goes,
well no one told you to get my name
tatted on you. Now you'll get fucking ass.
Oh my damn. Have you ever done anything
for a girl? Like a tattoo? Yeah.
You know, so I've three characters
here.
This is back when I was young enough
when a tattoo shop was able to convince
you, which I think they still do.
The people that Chinese characters
can say or spell anything,
which is just not true. Well, like
what's supposed to be letters. So I got,
when I believed Chinese characters
was CMS, they're still there.
Uh, they're just blended into
something else. But it was
Sherilyn Marie Sleeter was, uh,
was the name of my girlfriend when
I was a terrible name. Yeah. Yeah.
All Sleeter she sounds like she's got
shit teeth infamous now. Good teeth.
Sheriffs. Leary says,
I see have fucking teeth pointing
in every which direction. Hot
CIC actually. But, uh, just, I mean,
coming from like a real pack of dummies,
like real stupid and so
stupid. In fact, was she,
that I got those tattooed on me. Thank
God. And Chinese characters, CMS.
Her mom didn't like me and I came,
I couldn't wait to tell her mom
that I got this tattoo. I go,
look what I got for your daughter. And
she's like, what does that go to CMS?
And she goes, what's that? I
go, your daughter's initials.
Sherilynn Maria's leader. And
she goes, uh, her mom could,
she was so happy to go. That's not
your name. My girlfriend was so dumb.
She didn't know her name is not, in
fact, she just made up the Murray part.
Her name is Cheryl Lynn
Sleeter and it was that.
So I got a wrong tet to have a
girl from that. She was perfect.
She was with me while I got it and
didn't know her own middle name.
Sat there confidently like,
make sure you get the m good.
Yeah. That's, that too is
wild large patches of America.
That is, that tattoo,
that tattoo like that.
That's that fucked up bodies so
many lives. Oh yeah. So many people.
So many people have made horrendous
choices. Yeah. I had my first tattoo.
It just said, uh, Lew dog. I
gotta cover it out. But Ludo, l,
U. D. O, g, g, nobody has
ever called me Lou dog,
except for afterwards sarcastically to
make fun of me. They're like, all right,
Lou dog is there, but you were so sick
to go tell your friends. Hey guys,
you're calling me Lou dog. It was weird
cause I only had $70 and I was like,
all right dude,
I have $70 I'm 18 I just turned 18 I was
like getting a fucking tattoo and I was
like, all right, I'm going
to Ludo no matter what.
But I gotta get like a
little design underneath it.
[inaudible] script and
then underneath it it was,
it was tribal like almost they
had walls look like, like antlers,
like tribal antlers. But
it was because I was poor.
Some you would like scribble on a binder
while you're bored in class. Dude.
It was just, it was like
there was a tramp stamp.
It was like about tiny trash stamp
underneath Lou dog for no reason.
Were you under age? No, I was 18
oh, I was under it.
That's why my mind is the word Jay and
old English and it is so high up here to
so my mom wouldn't see it.
Oh right. You sold immediately. Why
was the hide it under your tee shirt?
We were both fat kids and I had a big
fat arms with this little tiny shit that
too. And my big fat arm. And your j
is so tiny, it's so tiny. It's still,
they're all bad. It's bad. It's
bad. Yeah, it's that, yeah.
Then more Chinese stuff here and then
a Pam Anderson Barbwire wire around my
arm. But I've just accepted all my tattoos
of some shitty dumb stories in high
school.
My friend Jimmy was the first one to get
tattooed and he got this really shitty
like tiger on his arm with his name
case if he gets his name, you know,
I think we were like 18 at the time,
maybe 17. And he came home and uh,
he had like a little bandaid
peeking out underneath his shirt.
His mom started screaming at him
and if I'm, I hope I'm not re,
I'm fucking this story up. I hope I'm not,
but like are I remember thinking that
like, wow, he was the first, like,
everyone's got to get a tattoo eventually.
Like the idea that someone's gonna
draw on you permanent. I was like, Ooh,
forever. You've got to keep
it like it's a balls. Funny.
It never really hit me like that
hard, but I know it and it's true.
And by the way, I wish you know,
talk about having a time machine.
If you can go back and just tell your
teenage self like just wait til even like
your late twenties you're going to
have a lot of good years with awesome
tattoos.
We're going to make this decision now
and have the rest of your life with some
pretty shitty. You want money
when you're 18 you don't,
there's no money for good tattoos.
You probably from some Alicia
live in Miami 20 I've have,
I have $20 tattoos on me for sure. I was,
if I was offended by the drawing because
I'm an artist and I was looking at,
I was like this is so
bad. The guy just traits.
I mean the guy was not an artist
at all. Whoever did the tattoo,
he was fucking just a guy
who got a job doing tattoos,
who learned how to use the gun on my leg.
I have a dragon, like a, another
tribal dragon. I was 19 and Florida.
We Miami like we liked like on a boardwalk
tattoo shop with like Chinese people
in the front. Like they don't ever
get tired. Never going to tablets.
You're in China and they're using the
old like taffy techniques where they
fucking do that.
Don't go to like a Shit Bodega Tattoo
shop because that's what I got and it's
all blended together now. And the
guys had no idea. It's painful shit.
They don't know what they're doing.
The other problem with it is it's
really painful. They go too deep.
They pull it out. Well that's another
thing about [inaudible] ladies. If you uh,
or guys who are in the Henna Tattoos,
if you get those Hanna Tattoos,
I can Thailand or something like
that. Sometimes it's not really Henna,
it's hair dye and the hair dye
can be poisonous to your skin.
She's like not good stun. You didn't
even die getting a real tattoo. Wow.
You can die, but I think it fucks you up.
I'm getting painted on with hair dyes.
What a,
I think there was like a warning about
this that I've read where they're saying
don't don't get Hannah from places that
aren't using real Henoch cause they,
they use cheap hair dye. They could've
just stopped that dunk at Henna. Yeah,
you could have said that.
That's a weird one. Right?
It's like I want a tattoo but not
really. Yeah, it looks like a,
it looks like a spray
on Tan's wearing off.
It just looks disgusting.
P D is Con in it. Whatever.
Black can often contains PPD at high
levels and when that applied to skin can
cause chemical burns and allergic
reactions. And I don't know what PPD is.
I'm trying to find that chemical burns.
Yeah, you gotta be careful out
there. Kids don't do heels on you.
Joe Rogan says steer clear of Hannah,
drill holes in your skin and
pumped some ink in there.
It's apparently there
had to be like a, uh,
some errors made when they
were coming up with like tech.
Like the first tattoos, peoples arms
were fucking falling off their body.
I'm pretty sure the first
tattoos were like in Africa,
carving shit into your arm
or something. Scarring thing.
When someone's a great tattoo artists,
I'm always blown. It's the most sloppy,
uncomfortable with the fact that I
couldn't do anything near that with like a
pencil and art supplies and a set. Yeah.
You know flat surface like was it meant
to have to do that as correct when
someone's amazing at it, it makes no
sense. No it doesn't because they always,
also,
there's still just going like and just
scribbling basically it looks like and
then they swipe it away and it's like
they're mad at you. It's like, man,
I found the craziest fucking page.
Jamie, I'm gonna send it to you.
This is a lady and she does paint on
people's face that makes it look like they
have extra eyeballs and the,
the paint is so accurate.
You're looking at a video of it and you're
like, what the fuck am I looking at?
I have to say, is it the Asian check?
Cause she makes herself into different
do that. That chick is fucking talented,
which he does with makeup and she got
in trouble cause she did black face but
she does everything. She can do blackface.
She made herself into like
an African Nubian princess.
It was the most amazing thing
in the world. Is this her?
But it still has like the outline.
She was shucking and jiving.
She was choice. I'm a Newbie and
princess, whether you're talking
[inaudible] name is Mimi Choi.
This is the shit she does. Whoa,
look at that dude. That's
insane. Yeah. Your head.
She's got eyeballs drawn. All
those Rogan's perfectly well.
Yeah. That's like a tool
video. She's a fractal.
That is something you would see if you
were on some serious drugs and this is
the kind of shit you got to pretend to
enjoy where if you want to fuck a hot
Asian chick her, I'm super into
new dance. Like look at that.
Oh this is a different check
than I was thinking of, but yeah,
I guess there's a category.
It's cool. It's crazy.
If you go scroll down and look at some
of the eyeball ones where the extra
eyeballs are below or face
[inaudible] Jesus Christ.
That's a fucking freak out. It's
a fucking freak out. Yeah. Yeah.
That's so weird. Yeah, it's wild.
It's that same sort of level of tattoo
art that the really high level Tattoo
guy. Have you seen that Guy Steve
Butcher? I've showed you that guy before,
right? That guy walked into a room.
I would think that it's a monster
and I would kill it. Yeah. He like,
what the fuck? He was terrifying. Someone
drugged you. Yeah. You would see like,
Oh my God, Satan is real.
I've been budding around arrogant
thinking that Satan's not real. Yeah.
This is Steve Butcher. Steve Butcher
does insane shit, man. He did one of me.
Somebody got me tattooed on their
leg and it's fucking increase.
Do you feel about that Joe? So
weird. Don't do that. Don't do that.
Doesn't mean you can't say it to the guy
when he sends you a fucking just dump
stuff. God got Legion of skanks tattoo
on his face and like you look at you go,
that's awesome that you want to do that.
But man you maybe you shouldn't have
bunch of other face tattoos though.
It wasn't the first one. True. Who
that? Kobe Bryant. Scroll up a bit.
Look at that. Kobe Bryant. He's
got the tee shirt. His mouth.
Get the fuck Outta here man. That might
as well be a photograph. That's crazy.
Like look at the resolution. Look
at the sweat. If you said to me,
what's the one thing you can't
draw? I'd say black people sweat.
[inaudible] this guy
pulled it off somehow.
If I was drawing that we just
have white drips. Dennis failing.
You got like copied. Make that bigger
Jamie. That guy did that with needles man.
That's insane. How good that is. Yes.
Somehow it doesn't seem nearly as
weird to get athletes tattooed on you.
Is it those comedians does for
now? It's still [inaudible].
I'm sure Kobe's running
around going, damn dude,
that's a little different that
these people grow up on. Like,
I mean that's not true dude. Cause I,
the connection that people feel with
like comics and podcasts, it's pretty,
I get it. You know, it's like we
don't want the responsibility.
We want to do it, but we
don't want the response.
But I don't want the
responsibility of being your Shin.
I 100% want my fucking face tattooed
on people. So anybody out there I will.
I'll give you a free lesions,
gangs, t-shirts. There's the dude.
It's a good tattoo. It loves
it says Lou dog. That is crazy.
That's so that is as accurate
as a photograph. That
would suck my fucking face.
That's my face. That's fucking
intense. It's amazing. Yeah.
I don't remember what, that's fine.
I was probably making a point.
[inaudible] whatever it was. You were
right. [inaudible] problem with me, man.
You get any one clip of me or my face
and you could make decisions. That's a,
that's an incredible, ted says the
first time Joe saw always butthole.
There's no way I can remember
that far back. I think fun.
I think always said so many times.
I think he's in process of
getting his butthole fixed.
Is he going to get surgery? He's
been bleeding since I've known him.
It's bizarre that he just lives life like
that. That was shut. That's a problem.
That would shut me off from
going out to the world. What,
what causes those things? Hemorrhoids.
What causes hemorrhoids? Hemorrhoids.
Working out. Cause I wasn't breathing
when I was lifting weights and I was just
clenching, just clenching my butt hole.
And it just popped out like
squeezing a balloon animal.
You made blisters inside your butthole.
Wheezing it together for a while. Well,
this is actually how we got introduced
to Ari's butthole was I was complaining
about me having hemorrhoids
and I'm leaving to skanks.
We opened up my butthole to show
them. I showed all the guys did it.
We didn't call open up. We said, that's
not a ham roll. And we're like, what ax?
You call that a hemorrhoid. Oh,
that's step aside. Little ladies,
let me show you a hemorrhoid. And it was
like, no, it was like the uh, you know,
and stranger things. The fucking
monster, the way the face opens up,
that's what all always asshole does.
Looks like Yammer. Simpson's mouth. Yeah.
Remember like the blade, remember
the blade vampire mouse. Predator.
Predator.
It's baggy but it just cause it
opens a lot the way it opens.
How does he get away with what he gets
away with? Dude? He like, he keeps,
he keeps tissues in his
asshole at all times.
And if you're with Ari at one point he
might just throw a bloody tissue at you.
If it got to, I get, I get staying
away from the doctors, I get it.
But if you're actively
bleeding out of your asshole,
I'd be on an operating table
face down, click quick.
I think it's a real pain in
the ass to get the surgery.
I liked it and dealing with it as is.
You don't know yet. But I mean it's, I'm
glad he's going to get it fixed though.
It's troublesome. When your friend says,
how many times did that guy send you
a picture of bloody toilet paper?
I've seen way too much, way too much
[inaudible] people. The height
up thing to me is that, uh,
Ari historically is just crushed ass
like hot chicks walking around with the
confidence guy. He's confident walking
around with Napkins, weirdly handsome.
Like you don't think you'd
see me? Like, all right,
that's a fucking goofy camel
face. Fucking asshole. Yeah,
but then you look at him again.
He kinda has dreamy eyes dreaming and
he's in good shape. I don't know, man.
He got in good shape for sober
October. He's a fucking animal.
I knew that he was going
to be a real problem.
He was trying to win that God damn
thing. That's not right there, dude.
You can't fucking have a athletic
competition with all of your add a shape,
fat friends. It's not fair. But
they were willing to do it. I'm like,
okay, good luck. I'm like, look,
we're gonna, we're gonna work out seven
days, seven days, six hours a day.
We're going to have to do that. We're
gonna see who drops. This is not smart,
but I understand it because they're sober.
Ari came the closest, arguing close.
He got close. He went
hard. He went fucking hard.
If Ra was in shape going into it,
he would probably would've at least
what's gotten a lot worse? Winning.
Millie, how do you win? Do you
have this? Uh, this is last year.
Last year was the only time we met at a
competition and I think it's better off
not being a competition. Honestly.
I think the first year we had to
do 15 yoga classes over the month,
1590 minute hot yoga classes, which
is annoying. Yeah, it's annoying.
Like you don't want to do it, but you
have to do it. Like can you get in there?
All right, number seven, like,
and you're starting to think
how many more days are there?
I'm going to have to do a bunch of work.
I want up having to do nine in a row.
So I did yoga nine fucking days in a row,
but it would know it was no competition,
but we just had a requirement and
everybody met the requirement.
We felt good that we
accomplished the goal together.
But then everybody started talking
crazy. They wanted to do a competition.
And Tom was like, yeah, let's wear these
a heart rate monitors. I'm like, okay,
all right, we're all gonna
die. So what was, how did you,
how would it Ari of one,
like what was the point system it
based on 80% of your heart rate,
right? So your [inaudible],
it finds your Max heart
rate and then you know 80% of that gets
you x amount of points and 90% of that
gets you y amount of points. I forget
what it is over a course of time. Yeah,
but you can't really maintain
90% 90% is like the sprints.
The real smart move is a
stay at 80 and go longterm.
So we were doing these cardio workouts.
It's all just in your head
cause it's not hard to do.
It's not hard to do an elliptical
machine. It's an easy motion.
So it's all in your head and all you
do is you wear this fucking heart rate
monitor.
And what I did is I watched the murder
scene from John Wick where it goes into
the Russian bathhouse and over again.
I'm on a loop for five hours and I just
stayed on the fucking elliptical machine
for five hours watching that scene and
I get to the end of that and I'd rewind
it and I'd watch it. I'd be
like, ah, music fucked up.
And I just, I did it for fucking
six, six hours a day, seven hours,
six hours a day. That's psychotic
while we were having a competition.
[inaudible] it's probably not healthy
to work, but it's not helpful.
Like [inaudible] we were competing.
Yeah, we know we're going to hell.
We're going to hell. I'm like, we're
going to hell. There's no way. Bert,
Bert Kreischer was the one
who talked the most shit.
So I would think about him while I
was getting tired and I was like,
there's no way bitch. There's no way
you're going to die. We're all gonna die.
Let's just go. We're going
to go til there's no sleep.
Is there an advantage to starting off
being like one of the fattest guys because
you kind of lose more
instead of, no, no, no.
Your body's going to have
a hard time recovering.
80% of your max heart rate is different
than 80% of my max heart rate.
So technically I don't have to
work as hard as you, you know,
you'd have to run on, you
know, seven on a treadmill.
I could run at a 4.5 but no, I think
it's based on your age as well.
So the Max heart rate is different.
So it might actually be easier
because it's just used to doing it.
It's all about your body being
used to doing. If you're using,
you're looking out [inaudible] percent
is only like 140 beats a minute,
you know, or maybe a little bit
more like one 46 beats per minute.
That's not that bad. Like you can kind
of do that for a long time. He goes,
sh what's like,
she just watched something that's engaging
and make sure you keep breathing at
that rate and you get, you get
trapped in whatever you're watching.
And for me it was fights
too. That was a big one.
I just put on some great fights.
So I got a TV right in front of me and
I'm on this fucking elliptical machine
watching fights and I would drink gigantic
jugs of water with Himalayan salt and
all these different hydrators right up.
No, to keep your hydrated [inaudible].
Okay. I see that sweet,
sweet, delicious water.
I sweat so much that I set
off the fire alarm. What?
I filled the room up with so much
steam that the fire alarm went off.
I filmed it good. I put it
on youtube or on Instagram,
but it was ridiculous.
If you make me so mad,
Dave's never worked out a day
in his fucking life. He's just,
there's gotta be a few.
They look, yeah, he looks good. He's
handsome. My point was, Ari got close.
He got close to me. He wasn't even
working out. That's how crazy Ari is.
And then you have to deal with the fact
that you're doing this publicly and you
can't allow already to beat you with
this thing. I was in normal hour, Burt,
if our he beat me, I would have said
Mao, man, I would've, I would've said,
wow man, that is really,
really impressive.
But there was no fucking way
[inaudible] Tom, if Tom beat me,
I'd be like, dude, you did it man. Wow.
I wish I won. But you won Burt. No Way.
There's no way we're going
to hell. You just leave.
We never hear from your
again. Go into the darklands.
I'm wearing that monitor
on me all day long.
I'm just going to be lifting weights
everywhere I go far back was Burton the
stairs? He's barely
working out talking shit.
What did he do? Was it a marathon he
ran or something? Half Marathon. No, no.
He ran a full marathon and he ran. It
was pretty impressive. It's insane.
Burt's tough. All bullshit aside like
Burt talks, tremendous amounts of shit.
That's why I didn't want to
lose to him, but person tough.
I think you also talked shit to sort
of set the expectation for himself too.
Cause he says it,
he's going to fucking have to stick
to it because it's a very loose thing.
That's made it [inaudible].
We always talk about,
he speaks very declarative about things
and I'm like, why do you do that?
Hold myself to that standard.
If I say I'm going to lose weight publicly
and then I don't ever want to call me
a fucking phony, and if I,
if I keep it in my head,
I probably will be more likely to
skip the gym or whatever else it is.
That's really wise. That's really wise.
That's a good strategy. If you fail,
it works for better podcasting.
He's also true public acknowledgement
of your failings when it comes to like
little goals that you set up for you.
It's like lets everybody know, hey man,
this is not easy to do
comics and he, I dude,
we live in a social media generation.
It's all like, you need that.
I need people to tell me,
dude, you're losing weight.
And when they stopped telling me that I
get fat again and then they're like, oh,
you're getting fat. And then I start
losing weight again. I, and I'm,
it's almost that the attention
is sort of what motivates me.
I need something beyond
just being [inaudible].
How much time have you spent researching
different methods of losing weight and
how much you looked into intermittent
fasting? I've done in a minute. It did.
I've done, I've been assessed
try that. I've never,
I still don't fully
understand what it is. Simple.
You just have a small feeding
window like a, for me,
I like to fast f I feel at
my best on fasting 14 hours.
So what I'll do is, you know,
if I eat at 8:00 PM then I eat at 10:00
AM the next day. It's not that hard.
I was doing 12:00 PM to
7:00 PM I was eating,
I could eat from 12:00 PM to 7:00 PM. Um,
but I wasn't really eating healthy
things. What I was doing, I
[inaudible] thing I was eating shitty.
What I'm better at is if I
just cut out most of the carbs,
I eat fruit and shit like that.
But if I cut out all the carbs in the
burgers and the fucking bread and the
pasta and the rice, I can manage
that because I can get creative.
And if I'm the mood for pizza,
I can figure out a, you know,
a low carb version of pizza, you know,
Callie fire across or whatever it is.
Gay. Yeah. You know what?
You should just come to you
that it's really delicious.
Do all those things but also
lift weights. Yeah. I have been,
I just started again like two
weeks ago. That's a big one.
But lifting weights is huge.
It burns a shit ton of cowers.
And more importantly,
when your body has more muscle than your
body burns more calories so you can eat
the same amount of food and you lose
weight, you could do all that. Or Louis,
I know you just fist fight a
comedian. [inaudible] lose weight,
you'll lose body fat. Joe, you eat
like tons of meat. I eat a lot of meat.
Do you ever get, have you gotten
gout, uh, stuff ever gouts from meat.
Isn't that like a wine disease? What
do you get gout from? A lot of meat,
meat and beer on your feet and your
toe. It hits your fucking right big toe.
It sucks. I'm sitting in a chair for
too long and eating too much meat.
I think it's all those things. Your
heel too. Doesn't it? Fuck your heels.
Maybe. I don't know.
I haven't tried it hit it hit twice ever
and my toe was awful. But you had gout.
Yeah, but that was like, and by
the way it would hurt so much.
When I went to the doctor I was
like, I'll take, cause there's like,
you know you can get medicine for it
every day you take so you don't get it.
And I would have absolutely taken that
as how much it hurt and they go, no,
you don't have like a condition. You
know what I mean? Like I think I just,
I went to like a festival of concerts
one weekend and [inaudible] shit.
Gouty definitely shout it
up. Here's the definition.
Gout occurs when you're eight crystals
accumulate and your joint causing
inflammation and intense
pain of a gout attack.
Your eight crystals can form when you
have high levels of uric acid in the,
in your blood, your
body produces uric acid.
When it breaks down Purina substances
that are found naturally in your body.
I got his blood that still didn't answer
my question. What's Jane Cause here it,
I got people at ease up on
the foods, meat, poultry,
seafood co chemical compounds that are
high amounts and certain foods like meat,
poultry and seafood. That's interesting.
I think you also have to be fat hypo.
Uremia yeah, my friend was not fat.
I'm hyper Yersinia it sounds
like something that a fat
person should only get
though. Dude, I lied. I was on
a flight yesterday and I lied
and uh, because we,
we were on the runway for two and a
half hours and I was just getting really
impatient. I was like, I'm fucking hungry.
I mean I made up that I was
hyperglycemic to get food.
I buzzed, busted thing
and they wouldn't come.
So eventually I started just like waving
like a mad man. And Mike [inaudible],
who's a friend of ours, a
comic, he was a few rows up.
This is how he knew what was on the plane
cause I was being a lunatic and I was
like, we've been on here
forever. Oh, I'm hypoglycemic.
I need food right now man. I'm
like, don't get me orange juice.
It was the most fucking embarrassing
thing, but here, suck a lemon.
Keep getting me two and a half hours.
When you're angry on a plane
that's not going anywhere. It's,
I'm blown away by the amount of rules.
Like when you've been at the gate
for like two hours before, I'm like,
can I just go back into the
airport? And they're like,
now like it doesn't make any sense to
you and not like take the flag and like I
want to, I'm off. I
think you can be lifted.
Doors closed a big deal if you
want to. That's a big deal.
But as a Puerto Rican, if you do leave
Louis, you have to twerk on your,
I don't know if you watch those videos
when people leave playing, they go fine.
Oh fuck. They all used
to work their way out.
You will get put on a list for sure.
If your asshole every
time you fly on a plane.
Well Lewis already has that
problems. He flew my guessing.
Do you think that they would probably
check you if you decided I want off the
plane right now and if you make a
scene, pull the plane back into.
They'd be like this guy,
that's my [inaudible].
You don't think you're not gonna
get off unless you make a scene.
You won't get up once
it's away from the gate.
I'm talking about when they stay at the
gate and they never actually pull away
from like the a Yadda plane. You just
hoping everyone can keep it together.
Yeah. Hoping. Just hoping
everyone can keep it together.
What's your craziest playing
experience? I hate, I hate flying and,
and I've had plenty of weird ones.
Two dudes [inaudible] almost get after
it once on a plane over overhead space.
This one guy was claiming
the space overhead.
There's only four or five arguments
you could have on a plane over space.
Middle person gets both armrests
this one guy was on this side, right?
But his shit was all filled up,
so he opens up the bin on the other
side and puts his bag in and sits down,
and the guy who was behind him,
that was his side. He goes, hey man,
that's my storage space. He goes, no,
it's not. He goes, it storage space.
I put my bag in there first I was in, I
was ahead of you. I put my bag in there.
He's like, no, you have yours and
I have mine and yours is full.
And he goes to grab his shit
and the guy goes, hey man,
don't touch my fucking
bag. Right. By the way,
the guy who took the other source
space, you don't have, it's not,
it's not a personalized
source space. Fuck off dude.
It's just storage space on first-class.
I wish one of those degenerate
fucks from the back.
We'll try to put some shit in my storage
space. I flew first class one time.
They almost went after it though.
The, the waitress had to cut them off.
She cut them up. We're
in the air waitress, Joe,
we're in the air and they're going at
it again, so it's like wheat there.
They were going at it
when they were about,
the plane was about to take off and then
they got through it and then the air,
they were going at it again. The waitress,
the stewardess, she cuts them off.
Wouldn't let them have alcohol, but
it was tense, so it's like, you know,
you have to keep an eye on.
I was going to say like the whole time
she fell with me, the lady made me,
she's like, you're going to help me
ride. I'm like, Jesus Christ lady.
Anything's going to happen. Well, you
see my girl, right? The woman behind me,
as I was complaining, she was like, and
I was like, I was like, yeah, you know.
He was like, well, what do you want to do?
I was like some orange juice and coffee,
maybe a kind bar. That'd be nice.
He goes, I should like loud
enough for me to, she goes,
just get him some orange juice, and I
went and turned around and was like,
mind your this lady. Shut
the fuck up lady. These guys,
those undercover dudes that are on
planes or Marshall's air marshals, right?
So if you're an air Marshall
and you see these two,
two guys getting after a little bit,
just talking shit, grabbing bags,
just shoot them Dickie to each other.
Wendy move in because you don't want
everybody to know you're an air Marshall.
You're like, they don't have a bomb.
You guys gotta work this out like you
fucking pussies are just going to push
each other like you're not. You
know you guys aren't terrorists.
What am I doing here? Just a
an architect and a fucking,
if somebody wanted to have a fighter
plane and give up their entire fucking,
it's such a pain in the ass.
What did you're going to deal with
to get into a fist fight on a plane?
I don't know how many different
crimes it is. I have to,
but they have to pull this fucking
plane over. You are fucked dude.
You have to really want to fight somebody
in order to do that because you'll
deal with a lot of shit, but you're
going to get to that point plane.
You're going to like one
Tonomys they arrest you.
You saw that lady smack her boyfriend
in the head. The guy gets up,
he's trying to leave and she
throws the laptop and yeah,
as as he's walking down
the aisle. Yeah. All right.
I didn't see who threw a
laptop right there in the air.
This is going to lady's screaming at
their sewing laptop. Yeah. She's like,
you ain't shit.
He'll say she's fine if she catch her
boyfriend cheating on the plane or
something like that. Weird.
But she got super loud and it became
like a huge scene where everybody was
listening to her, talking to him. It
was like, oh my God, this is so crazy.
I mean, when they were dragging
the Asian guy out of the planes,
one of the funniest videos of
all time, I wanted to go home.
He just wanted to go. He started chanting,
I want to go home, but it was so sad.
They would legitimately have to drag
me out if they were trying to get me to
give up my seat, they would have to drag
me out of the plane. They can do that.
Imagine thinking they could do that.
We just got to grab you physically and
take you off the show. Like come on,
you're you're, you're on the plane.
The plane's about to take off.
We're going to grab you and just pull
you out of there and [inaudible] I think
they probably just settled with them.
They probably just gave him a ton
of money and said shut the fuck up.
Because at what point it is your price.
Find out what type of business
they do have security.
I mean what point does somebody
wants to leave your private business?
I'm sure it's within the, the,
the contract that you fucking the terms
of service for the ticket that they can
do that. So you think so where
the guy's already sitting down?
Well he's saying no after they
asked him to leave a lot of times,
so I don't know what the law is.
I mean if it's his ticket
and he bought the ticket,
you can just decide if you've got times
of service. So ridiculous. Exactly.
You're right Logan saying it's
a terms of service. Dumb line.
They can do anything they
want. Anything they want.
Well what happened is they got
destroyed on social media for like weeks
afterward and they apologized and we're
like, we're changing our policy and
[inaudible] don't even
get me fucking started.
Joe Starbucks or American Airlines says
officially thank God that guy wasn't
black. I fucking,
I live in Harlem and the Starbucks in
Harlem. I mean it looks like a bus depot.
It's crazy.
It's just lines of people just sitting
there charging their cell phones,
not ordering because they had their
new policy is everyone that walks into
customer, their customer says,
what's the fucking all it happened
because of one bad PR Philly,
Philly.
When these two black dudes would just
trying to sit down and chill out at,
at Starbucks and someone decided to
remove them from the premises. Yeah,
but look now take
[inaudible] cause here's what happened.
I know that you have opinions on all
I'm saying, the Libertarian perspective,
they might've been Dick.
Starbucks might've been Dick's,
but what I know is they, they asked
them to leave. They called the cops.
The cops weren't going to arrest them.
The cops told them you have to leave
and they still refuse to leave and then
they didn't. Then they let them go.
They literally just cuffed him and took
him to the station and they were like,
we'll just charge him with any,
they also tried to order four loco,
so they were out. But here's what I know.
I know that we don't know what happened.
Yes, no, I agree with that completely.
You don't know. It was
a human interaction.
You don't know who the con was
there. It could've been them.
It could've been the person worked.
I know what fucking happened,
but I know exactly what happened. Things
happened. These two guys walked in,
they didn't buy anything. They were like,
Oh yeah, you guys gotta buy something.
They were like, no, we don't. They're
like, well, you got to leave that.
And they're like, no, we
don't. And it was just weird.
A little Mexican standoff between a
fucking dumb idiot Starbucks employee and
two dummy days. It wouldn't leave
a Starbucks. Well, here's the deal.
Here's the screening was around Mexican
standoff between blacks and some
Chinese.
Do you think that the influx of homeless
people is bad for their business?
Do you think it's hurting business
at all? Absolutely. I mean,
I imagine like that one
move from that one store,
if the wings of the butterfly from that
one little incident creates like a a dip
in the value of the company.
I feel like people wouldn't want to hang
out there as long and you probably buy
more shit if you like stay there.
There's probably people who go up
online a couple times if they're there,
you know? Right,
and you don't want to write your script
on your laptop while a guy shitting his
pants next to you. I know we're
four morons, but let's solve this.
Like why are there,
why are there so many homeless
people and what could be done?
I think that's a real tough area.
That's like the thing that they used to
do is just institutionalize them. Right.
Just fucking grab them and throw them
and there's some problems with that for
sure. But who decides who's worthy of
being institutionalized and you know,
we get hunt them at night,
like Nutria at night.
Here's there. They just go around
with the thinking of the shooting.
I didn't tell you that
on his show. [inaudible]
you wouldn't do trio hunting. Yeah,
it's bad out here man in New York.
But you guys got real bad here. You
ain't seen shit until you go downtown.
Downtown la makes everything. If
post up pass every underpass in La,
now you're, you're subject to see
tents. They're all over the place.
All over through the valley.
Homeless people in La and New York are
pretty friendly though. They're not,
they're not that aggressive.
I was in Seattle.
Those fuckers who will come up
to you and they will go at you.
They want like [inaudible]
give them money.
They will like give you an attitude
about it everywhere else too.
Like a Cleveland horrible homeless,
like every other city besides San Fran,
like yeah. Really. It's
like the aggressive shit.
The Canadian homeless are the shittiest
and most aggressive where a kid,
what not. Like this was around
when we, when we were kids,
you would see those boxes on the side of
the road and it was usually someone who
is so fucked up that you know, they,
they just couldn't go anywhere and
they'd have a box and they used,
smelled like shit and
they were covered up.
But we're seeing like different
levels. You grow up suburban. Yeah.
[inaudible] I grew up in Brooklyn.
I saw homeless people all the time,
but I never saw anything and
I haven't seen it in person,
but I've never seen anything like
the camps and stuff that I've seen.
That's insane. Yeah. That's the
new thing. Yeah, that's what's new.
It's like the underpasses too. When I,
when I first started coming here in
94 there was never any tents on the
underpasses, at least I
don't remember that being,
I think now there's like almost
some people think it's cool.
I live in east village,
New York and there is so many
just kids that you're like,
you're a phone call away from
like solving this problem.
You kind of want to be out
here like that. [inaudible]
just like there. It's literally
like some the heroin kids,
they all like punk rockers, 20 year old,
19 year old white kids who are
clearly on out just like 20 though.
[inaudible] that's what I'm saying.
Big Kids. They're a fomo bustle. I bet.
I bet you those kids are from really,
really fucked up situations at
home and around the drugs and some,
I think more often than not
they're probably dealing
with the fucked up shit at
home. You don't end up on the streets
to to you know, rebel against your mom.
You're good. Mom and dad,
most of the time I'm sure it happened
also watching a guy like you know who just
looks like a as Crotty is homeless can
be like charging his phone on one of
those stations is pretty
flick. Everyone just doesn't,
where's your address for
bill? Yeah. How is this?
Do you have that too? Yeah.
Who's billing has Verizon get you the
bill every month, prepaid phones anymore.
[inaudible] New York is on every corner
now. They have like a big station,
right? And on that station you
could do literally free phone calls.
You could just dial a number.
It's a speaker phone, phone call.
You could charge your phone
and it has like a Wifi station.
So everyone on the street has
wifi in New York and you're like,
this is a great idea.
Except now there's always a homeless
person literally plugged into it.
And that's now their power source
for their little homeless thing.
They were jerking off outside. They had
to take the screens off the screens off.
There was about a week after they came
out where you'd see regular people using
them and now it's only homeless
people like nobody else touches them.
If you had a look at a graph of all the
crimes that were committed using burner
phones, like seven 11 burner phones,
like how many seven 11 burner phones
are used by poor people and how many of
them are used to commit crimes like
serious espionage between like Liz
[inaudible], international spies,
fucking giant international crime tool
that goes unreported burner phones like
seven 11 burner phones. We get it.
It's in the plastic. You pop it open,
it's got an hour in it. Fuck.
Who the fuck is using those things? Some
of them are poor people. It's getting,
I think it's getting more and
more exclusively criminal.
Even pulls like leaving their planes.
Just like leaving an airplane.
If you buy a seven 11 phone,
you're on a list. Well,
you could go to like Verizon and get
a bottom of the line phone that's
affordable. That's better than anything
that existed like five years ago.
Like where technology is now. You don't
have to spend like, what's a cheap,
what's a cheap android phone?
If you were going to [inaudible]
at your pcs right now,
get a free android phone sign up
for $40. Right? And then you're out,
you're out the door and then you never
have to pay it again because it's
prepaid. Yeah. So you just have a certain
amount of minutes, right? Well no,
it's unlimited. I have, I have metro
pcs guys and I uh, if you're homeless,
you make fun of me. Do you have
the general insurance to you?
Just do everything. It's a phone
call. So as online rights online,
I get everything unlimited fuck off.
I don't understand why I would ever switch
besides for the fact that my friends
make fun of me. I'll sell your phone
works in places. It works everywhere.
You're doing some sort of a roaming
thing, I guess. No, there's no roaming.
There's no overture over, just
nothing. It's just better. There's,
it really sounds like we're
doing a fucking ad read of
parametric pts right now.
It's one of the UFC sponsors.
But people make fun of you like your
hot garbage and then not tell people
the truth. Cause you
screenshot everything.
Anytime I screened some shots on that.
It says Metro pcs in the corner. Tampons,
pictures, Instagram, scratch down. Put
boost mobile makes it that much better.
Mobile. Even if they're great, they're
embarrassing. Oh yeah. Right. Yeah.
Even if they're great. It's
embarrassing that it's great.
Like I think Hyundai has a problem with
these new cars that they're making.
So they started calling them the genesis.
They started calling them
Hyundai's cause people are like no,
no Hyundai Hyundai's that car that costs,
it's real cheap but it runs forever.
That's a Hyundai. There's no, no,
no Hyundai's luxury. We've got this,
lighten that up. Nope. Nope. Can't
have both. Yeah, they got handed. Yeah.
Make sure pcs, even if it's the best
service, you know like the, the,
the problem is like anytime
anything is a bargain,
even if it really is a great deal and
metro pcs seems like a great deal. It is.
It does. Anytime with things that
bargain, people don't want it.
Like some people want the shit that
costs a lot and it's hard to get.
And when I was a kid, I remember I would,
I just wouldn't get sneakers that
weren't like Nike's or like, yeah,
it even for they were
comfortable sneakers. Even
if they were more expensive.
Yeah. It didn't matter. This kind of
like a loser. I felt the fucking idiot.
You got home every day like a rebel.
If you want Adidas Grocery store
sneakers, I don't give a shit now.
It's funny how important it
is when you're younger though.
It's very important because anything that
could get you just ridiculed when you
were young you had to be always conscious
of like you had to always be aware of
what could fuck up your day.
There's not enough of a
delineation between shitty
stuff and like the mid range
stuff,
but I think like high end stuff tends
to be like better quality and stuff.
She's always shown that with clothing
and stuff or like my ex wife I remember
always was talking about per
how much you spend on a purse,
which I said is ridiculous
and she goes put,
it lasts forever and to some degree I
still think it's ridiculous to do that.
For a purse, but my point is paying
for the quality like does last longer.
It's better things are made better Smith.
But the difference between like a knock
off fucking Louis Vuitton bag and like a
bag you'd buy in like a store.
It's like not much difference.
It's not like a fake Ferrari.
There's a huge difference
between those bags I think.
I don't remember seeing a thing. My Dad,
my dad used to base it in the
fashion moms are like the stitching.
I mean like I did a check,
it was a fashion check. Yeah,
there's definitely a huge difference in
those bags. Yeah. Yeah. I'm agreeing.
I said, but like high end and I'm saying,
but I'm just saying the difference
between like this one you'd buy it like JC
penny versus like a shitty
one you'd buy on the street.
There's not much difference in quality
in that you might as well as buy the fake
Louis Vuitton if you are a kid and
you didn't have like a good name brand
sneaker, you were shamed Bobos
yeah, they call them the Bobo.
I Voight's. I remember when
I was in the sixth grade,
they were voids and there was, that
was the last shitty sneaker I ever had.
It was just vo I t got them at
ch warns, which was this, I mean,
as Shitty of a department store as you
could possibly get and a kids would just
make fun of your shitty sneakers.
It was terrible. I had lottos.
I had lottos that had velcro on the side
that you could change the lotto symbol.
Different colors, like a
fat fucking cheerleader.
I was dressed like a cheerleader. The
change, the cohorts go my school spirit.
If you are, if you are like a runner,
maybe get away with new balance.
Yeah. There were people wore new
balance when I was in high school.
I feel like that was like, okay,
it's okay. You're alternative you,
it's a good quality shoe. Okay.
Marvin Hagler used to wear
them like at a six gels.
People thought you had an arch problem
or you were a wrestler. [inaudible] he's,
Oh yeah. 86 wrestling shoes. By
the time high school came around,
I knew I knew well enough
to just change my style,
so I'd saw her on like air walks
and like those shitty like skaters.
They were like 45 bucks a pop. Good
move. Yeah. That was very smarter.
So it was a big Genco Jean Guy. Converse,
chucks never went out of style. Right.
They never went out of style. Also
never been comfortable. Loved them.
You think they're comfortable? I have
them, but I like, they're not comfortable.
I don't want smooshy. I don't like
smooshy shoes that much. Sometimes I do,
but most of the times I like it where
it's very, it's very little rubber.
That's all it is.
It's like you may imagine that those
guys played basketball and those things
back in the day. It's kind
of crazy. Yeah, that's weird.
It seemed like a lot of support,
but maybe that's that they had
stronger ankles that way or something.
My mom tried to convince me that
Chuck's were cool and she was right.
This was when I was in the sixth
grade. Oh, they weren't? It wasn't. No.
This was when Chuck's had the, you know,
Congress was at the absolute bottom.
They fucking, there's not that happened.
Here's the thing, it's cool again,
but it's not, I think I feel
like Chuck Taylor, 27 bucks.
I feel like Chuck Taylors were
always in style. A little converse.
Like just as a general brown. If you
had to just converse sneakers, dude,
you look like a jerk off quicker.
You're definitely your
family better be Porsche.
I have other problems like with your pants
and shirt before we even get to those
[inaudible] sneakers if you're
wearing [inaudible] time,
but that period of time is
gone. Right? They, they,
they have the dope leather and Suede
ones. They have all kinds of different,
what's that guy that now it's
like the look now it's like the,
so if someone makes feel us back somehow.
Tongue feelers in the back for kids.
Yeah. Like for kids is their one,
we don't know. We're so out of the loop,
but is there one brand that's like,
is it still Nike? Like what is Nike
and Jordan? My daughter is 17 so yeah,
that's still still, yeah. Yeah. Nike
is my cake timberlands. My kid has,
sure. Yeah. If it's,
if it's boots at the timberline gotta
be like the most successful sneaker
campaign in the history of the known
university. Yeah. Without a doubt.
There's nothing that has
the kind of cache as Jordan.
The only thing I'd say maybe probably
that sells more than the Jordan is the Air
Force One. But their per unit cheaper
though, right? That's no. Michael Jordan,
Nike, Nike Air Force
One. I think of him now.
Now the air force ones are the
bottlers at their basic. Yeah.
Doesn't the Air Force One have a dude
flying through the air? Duncan? No,
that's just the Jordans. I'm so white.
Nike's are fucking uncomfortable.
Every time I wear Nike, they hurt my feet.
Like a feat to Vegas to Vegas
statement. These are uh, what are these?
You're in the skate shoes, right?
Minimalist sort of. Yeah. There we go.
So the flexible, I love shoes. Yeah. Yeah.
And then I wear new balance.
I wonder balance a lot. Yeah.
Like an old white guy. Yeah.
That's a wide foot shoe. Yeah.
You take a bold risk when you
wear those five finger shoes,
even though they're good for
you. Oh, those, those good.
I've never showed a pair on there
to walk around in life though,
or just at the gym. My friend Kyle
Kingsbury does it, but he was also life.
He's also a gorilla. He's an enormous guy,
so he's daring you to say that or he's
going to climb a tree. Super Nice Guy,
but he's a former UFC fighter.
Super Nice guy and wears those fucking
five finger shoes. Kyle on Instagram.
He's hilarious. He's great. Great,
great to call. Is He a white guy? Yeah,
I say that only there was a thing.
I saw a clarity ring girl. Right?
What's her name? Tasha smoking.
There was a clip the other week.
You have two guys, two black
guys at a tow truck company,
I think it is that start filming this
white guy that called them gorillas and as
he fell,
but the white guy backing down as they're
coming at him and it's so funny why
this guy would have said this. Like, I
almost believed the white guy's excuse,
but he has lost cause he was,
I guess he said something like,
have one of these two gorillas, bring
it around. And he definitely met there,
big guys. So he definitely
kind of made it like that,
but it just doesn't look
good. So him explaining like,
you called me and my black
friends here, girl, he's like, no,
I mentally strong gut. But he just goes
out and I'm a strong guy. She goes,
my dentist is a black fella. He
just starts giving. So now he goes,
now that's where you're going.
Wrong brothers talking about y'all.
Dentists being blessed tend
to mailman's a black fella.
He comes way too far removed.
That's not even I hive high five Tim
several times. I don't even believe them
until later. Yes, I do. Sweet.
So wheat. So, uh,
I saw the thing where Milo said you guys
cooked out on the show the first time.
That's why we're going hard
on new balances this time.
It was worth it to have already went
already said fuck you to all three of us
was the hardest. I laughed and
[inaudible] fucking
fucking national treasure.
National Dude Orients Gang fasted,
rich vos and Bonnie Mcfarlane do a
show where they, they, it's cold.
You Bang him and they have like four or
five female comedians on stage and then
a male comedian comes out and
does a set at the end of it,
the girls have to decide whether or
not they would fucking base off of,
you know, a multitude of things and
the set, right. So Ari does his,
he just gets naked. It's like literally
take his clothes. I was like, oh,
it is set naked.
And then he starts chasing the female
Korean comedians around the stage with his
Dick and trying to happen,
hold on, listen, listen.
Before you say anything more,
but just be aware that other people
are going to listen to this. Yeah.
People are listening. He's like, got it.
Then he held her down against her will.
Then no, this isn't for this on camera.
This is not unknown. That was all,
it was all part of the
theatrical performance.
So it was planned and agreed to
and consented in advance cabaret.
So he's chasing, he's chasing these girls
around and really wink, wink, nudge,
nudge. He could catch them
if he was really chased.
Obviously he's a man or a
woman likes, oh my goodness.
He's chasing them around the stage
with his Dick and Louis C K is,
they're watching from the sidelines
and he goes, I'm the problem.
I think it did a lot to let Louis know
he was in a safe space. That was okay.
Here. There's a lot here.
A lot of people gather their panties
in a bunch when a, no pun intended.
When he went on stage. Oh yeah dude,
his set was fucking killing the,
they're so happy to
see him, man. Man, I'm,
I mean people outside of the people
that were there. Some people never,
I mean maybe they feel that the guy
didn't do what they wanted him to do,
but I mean how long do you
want someone to suffer? Well,
the bomber is also the venue saying that
like their workers were like afraid to
stop it or do anything about it and that
they were upset and it's like me walk
through word static. They don't have
to say that they were jumping around.
They didn't throw, because a business
doesn't need to have an opinion.
They could just not say
anything for two days.
Nobody was going after this
venue and going like, oh,
you need to release a
statement. Nobody gave a fuck.
Here's the thing is those
people are Tori for businesses.
But to understand that the, the idea
of reacting to a journalist is not new,
but the idea of reacting to thousands
and thousands of people make comments on
your Instagram page that is new.
And for a business that's, you know,
that that's a big deal. They, they,
they're worried about being boycott,
but that's not what happened.
But the people who are
pissed off that Louise there,
those people will not
like, they will boycott,
they will tweet every day. They, their
thing is to try to ruin someone for,
you know, committing a like woke
crime or whatever and there,
so that's what they deal with is
that people like us who are like, ah,
that sucks that they fucking wrote
that letter. We don't do anything.
We're not boycotting because they
wrote that letter. We're not like the,
the other side isn't putting
as much pressure on them.
And that's why all of these companies,
that's why Gillette's making those
razor commercials and shit cause they're
scared of that side. You see the
Gillette Razor commercial? Where the,
is it the Gillette one where the
two firemen kiss? I don't think,
I don't think I said
that. That will the cross
[inaudible] Army National
Guard. [inaudible] two firemen.
I wrote it down shit commercial
with who are you going for?
Like do they do gay guys
are gonna go, you know what,
we want to fight fires now. But it was
like, I get it, you're progressive.
It's like these, this God damn it.
I wanna know what the commercial
offensive though, isn't it like, dude,
if you buy into that like, like, oh my
God, I'm so happy this company is, is,
is woken you just a mark. They're
just taking advantage of you.
They're just trying to make money
off of you sorta. But it's also hot.
This is like a hot firemen and [inaudible]
friend and they're making out and
they, you know, the guy comes back from
a fire and he's ready to get some Dick,
right? Yeah. Holla. It looks fun.
It's a hero. As long as that lesbians,
they're trying to sell you insurance
or whatever the fuck they're selling.
I don't remember who did the commercial,
but I remember saying, oh, okay,
we're being progressive. I love it. Why
not? I don't give a shit. Go for it.
I just find it weird. I find it strange,
the woke capitalism thing that people,
that companies will take a position that
you think would turn off like 50% of
the people who buy from them. They do
it to prove they're there. I don't know.
Goodness, but it doesn't hurt.
Does it hurt? Like does anybody go,
Fuck Blue Cross, I'm getting my fucking
insurance from Spanish, broad, whatever.
Whatever the cheapest option
is. They're buying that.
It's like the equinox
thing that just happened.
Nobody's fucking leaving equinox.
Let me tell you something.
There's no other option. It's convenient.
You got your fucking gym membership.
A handful of people are virtue signaling,
but all the people complaining saying,
boycott Equinox on line. They're
not fucking equinox members,
so they're fucking fat.
[inaudible] cod equinox,
Steven or one of the owners was a
Trump supporter. He gave him money. Oh,
that's right. He held a
fundraiser last week for Trump.
So people were freaking out saying
to boycott the brand, but it's like,
where else are you going to go?
There's not another high end gym
that's all over the place like that.
Do you know the phrase on the
exact same political beliefs?
Weird runs a business? Like if I
go to, if I go to buy a sandwich,
do I have to go like, so where
were you on the Iraq war? No. Okay.
Let me check about this.
A company that praise on your laziness
is the insurance that you get through.
Like Sag-aftra. They like it's, you know,
you get it for free if you qualify and
then when you don't qualify for it,
you're still enrolled in it and it's
like the most expensive insurance.
Does that make sense? You
know what I mean? Like,
and they kind of praying that kind of
got me almost in that way where a year
where I, it wasn't taken
care of. I was like, well,
I don't want to switch out and
then have any doctors saying,
you know what I mean? Like
we should be different.
So they kind of get you like that to this
Trump thing is if you support anything
that he does, even just as business
practices, then you're racist.
Like everything that you support, if
he supports it, you're racist. Yeah,
that's crazy. You're, you're
a Nazi, you're racist.
And when somebody calls
you a racist or a Nazi,
even people that don't believe that,
they don't want to stand with you and
defend you because then they're being
perceived as defending a racist or a Nazi.
And it's a trick and it's very
effective. It was a juicy soap opera.
I don't know why this guy supports Trump,
but maybe he could explain it. Right.
And he's a real estate guy. He's a big
real estate guy, related properties.
It has nothing to do with this gym. Okay.
This has to do with the fact that he
probably has real estate deals for a very,
very long time with Trump and his, his,
his gym is inconsequential compared to
the billion dollar company that he runs.
Well that makes sense then. That makes
sense why he would support Trump,
especially if he knows Trump, but
it's uh, if you, you can't see that.
I mean if you have a problem with
that and many people would, right.
Many people would have a problem with
that. Like that's a different thing.
But if you, if you, if you
hear what people are saying,
they're saying if you support
Trump that you support racist.
So you support white
nationalists. You put,
and I think you're leaving so many people
out of the conversation when you do
that. Oh yeah. I mean
the guy got, what was it,
62 million people to vote for him.
So if you're saying anyone who
supports him is some type of Nazi white
nationalists, then we got bigger
problems. Definitely break up.
No one knows definition of
those things anymore. When my,
we used to be about Milo when he came
up to the things he was called that just
like, yeah, on paper couldn't
even apply to B, right.
Would never be accepted into
being a Nazi or a white supremacy.
Do you guys remember when we were kids,
we read about McCarthyism and the red
scare. We only always thought like,
God, we're past that. That kind of
Shit's never going to happen again.
But what that is is like a symptom of
people worried about people defecting from
their tribe or turning on their tribe.
And we have this like built in fear
of this kind of shit happening. Well,
there's that aspect to it, right?
It's the people who are worried about
people defecting and then you have the
opportunists who can play off that instead
of having a win an argument or having
to, you know, like convince
people, I'm just going to say,
you're with the other tribe.
You're in this bad group so you're
don't even talk to that person anymore.
Don't even listen to
what they have to say.
And if you're in some tribe on
every issue, you're a fucking adult.
I was going to say, why do you have
to be so defined by your choice?
You know what I mean? Like I would
love to hear the argument about the,
the what, what it does good for
him for his real estate ventures.
I would love to hear it like an honestly
laid out argument of why someone like
Trump's better.
If you're a real estate developer and
it might be a significant part of his
business. I'm like, I'm
not being an apologist.
People all people also will just like,
there's this weird thing where people,
people think that business owners and
people that make a lot of money are
inherently bad, but it's
like, I don't know dude.
Just cause somebody who's really good
and really successful. He's got kids,
he wants to feed, he has
grandkids. He wants to watch,
grow up and go to college.
It's like, I dunno,
I don't think this isn't necessarily
just bad people that have a lot of money.
I think that there's a lot of good
people that have a lot of money as well.
And I think they do a lot of good
shit. Well, I'll just, you know,
whenever someone gets
really upset about an issue,
you always have to wonder like how much
of it going in there was, I mean, what,
what is upsetting to you is upsetting
to that. Anyone who supports Trump,
like Trump rep represents all the things
that are wrong with America today in
terms of like white nationalists and
terrorist attacks and mass shootings and,
and, and, and massage
and keeping the massage.
They keeping the immigrants out and being
mean and being in America first like,
fuck, it's, uh,
it's one of those things
today where if you,
if you support any part
of that, any part of,
even if it's good for your business,
you're just a magnet for fucking people
who are angry at all the things that
whole list chick-fil-a,
McDonald's like, yeah, man,
epic businesses, successful businesses,
lightbulbs numbers, crazy,
right? People, electricity
diseases. A lot of big
businesses support Trump,
but it's so weird how people like project
their own thing. Onto the situation.
Cause even like that, you just said
like what everyone hates about Trump,
but the people who support Trump,
they're not even on the other side of
those issues. It's not like they're like,
no, we are pro white nationalists.
They just see him as a
completely different thing.
They're like making the country great
and jobs and draining the swamp and all
these other things.
Like they f people are looking at the
same thing and seeing very different
realities. Yeah. Yeah they are.
And people are going in
with their preconceived bias
and getting them confirmed,
you know, with everything. I mean,
even the way you looked
at the Mueller report,
like the Republicans looked at it as a
victory and the Democrats looked at as
some sort of a like a, an open door
to impeachment. Yeah. But that was,
I don't know if fucking, if
the thing starts off with, uh,
every day you're hearing on the news
that the president is colluding with a
hostile foreign power.
He's a Russian puppet.
He's working with Vladimir
Putin and then by the Andrew,
like we have to impeach him because
he thought about obstructing the
investigation that he was declared
not guilty. And it's like, ah,
this is getting weird.
You guys were going to be upset no matter
what you found a hundred percent Dave
loves Trump. It's dating. I'm trying
to say. Sounds like he does. He goes,
Trump, I'm going hard Nazi this time
and I'm not coming back on the show.
I'm going hard this time.
It's the fucked up part is
only having really two choices.
Like we're scrambling to
see who's choice number two,
who's going to be the
one that opposes Trump?
And you've seen people starting to
crack under pressure or [inaudible] like
re-entry pressure.
[inaudible] they're trying to figure out
who's going to be [inaudible]. Maybe.
Imagine. Imagine we all get doubted him.
It gets through and becomes
president won't be fucked.
When you look at the people
that are in line though,
does anybody stand out that you would
think that would be able to, I don't,
I don't know how much of a
realistic shot, but who I uh,
I love Tulsa Gab and I sent her money
twice already and I disagree with her on
like 80% of her shit. She
was real interesting person.
She very, she really is.
And her, she's dead on about the
war stuff and she's, you know, yeah.
About Medicare. Um, she, she's dead on
about a lot of things. She's kind of hot.
Fuck yeah. Dave didn't agree
with something that Medicare, no,
I don't like her medicare
stuff, but I do like a,
the most important thing that she
leads with is the war stuff. And she's,
she's got a great position where
she's like, did two tours in Iraq.
She's still active duty.
And so, you know, like the,
the normal like comeback is like, oh,
you're against the wars. It's like, well,
you're just kind of a wimp or you're,
you wouldn't want to protect the country.
And she's like, no
asshole. I actually went,
I'm the one who's willing to go die for
this and I'm telling you we shouldn't be
dying for this. And what did she do?
What was her job over there though?
Oh she was, it was serious.
She was like in a medical unit so she
was like dealing with the people who
actually [inaudible] a tree
though. She was making practice.
She cr the results of edge. It was
the edge of tomorrow to Tom Cruise.
It was her job to clean up the
DVDs. That's a hot subject, right?
Women in combat. Yeah.
I got a bunch of shit about st making
jokes about saying I don't understand what
a girl,
I watched the show cops a lot and I
don't understand what a good girl cop has
ever done in a situation. It's
hostile except for make the,
the perp get much more hurt.
Shot or tased because she's in the way
of it happening and people got really
upset about me saying that but it really,
I don't understand why you'd send like a
woman to a major fight happening at the
mall. Get down there ladies.
It really is like a puzzle.
The physical PR with some cops,
the physical aspect of
an altercation is like,
it's going to be a real problem with
plenty of guys. Plenty. You got cops,
the female thing, you can just say
you can't have 110 pound person.
Go and be the physical authority
in a situation. That element,
I'm going to call you
a chick officer chick.
Here's a terrible video of this guy
getting pulled over by this lady and his
daughter's in the car and the
guy was a criminal apparently,
and the cop was calling in and the guy
punches her and gets her down on the
ground. She knocks her out,
coats it all video. Yeah.
And starts punching her face and
while she and the daughter screaming,
stop it Daddy, stop it daddy. And he
beats the fuck out of this lady car.
And you're like, this is why it's problem.
This lady cops by herself
and she's got a gun,
but she doesn't have the gun out of
the holster polling at the guy. She's,
it's a routine traffic stop and that guy
pummels her man. It's horrible. Yeah,
it's a really shit and me
saying the idea's not like
fuck chicks. I'm just like,
don't send them out to
get hurt in the suits.
I don't understand why it's
not necessarily as your
daughter and you saw your
daughter beaten. Oh my God.
Because someone thought it was okay
for her to be by herself amongst,
you know, big giant criminals. Typically
they don't match up female cops though.
Right? I'm assuming most of the
time they put a girl by herself.
[inaudible] you can be on
patrol by yourself lives
just like walking around the
neighborhood or something for sure.
But I've seen videos where it's like a
dude and a chick partners and the cop
gets in a fight with another guy and
it's basically just two men fighting with
this woman kind of grabbing an arm
here or there and it's almost a
[inaudible]. She might try to hit
the guy with a brick and hit you.
That would be boring and Mace it herself.
But there's a lot of men that would
fall apart in that job too. Yeah,
sure. Oh definitely. Definitely.
I've seen, I think any small,
whether it's a woman or a man,
any person who's, you know,
not a large person who's not physically
strong is by themselves as a cop.
It's in danger. Any one, doesn't matter
if you're male or you're 150 pound male,
same deal.
You're in trouble unless you're really
good martial artists who can grab a gun,
quickly, know how to respond to pressure.
[inaudible] 99% of women, I could
take a gun right out of their hands.
I have no, I have no training,
but like give me your check.
You can point a gun right at
my head. But that said time,
I'm fucking taking it and putting
it right back at her. That said,
I should make clear that I myself,
I know where I'm nowhere near
as tough as I think you should.
You should need to be to be a cop.
Oh yeah. Do you know what I mean?
Like I would never assume that of myself
either. So I'm not like saying, dude,
I've been doing martial arts my whole
life. I wouldn't want to be a cop.
I don't want to be a cop. It's a crazy
situation. It's hard. It's a hard job.
It's dangerous. You're supposed to have
to be brave. Well not only that man.
Do you know how much PTSD those guys
are dealing with that is unrecognized.
If every day you're pulling
people over, that might shoot you.
Every day you're dealing with someone
who's robbing something or stealing
something or trying to kill somebody
or did kill somebody every fucking day.
You're going to see a lot of cops ain't
doing shit though. Some of them are.
But look, you are wearing a
uniform that makes you the enemy.
You're also the person with power and
you've got to realize how fucking corrupt
that is that you're able to yell at people
and force people in these situations
and cuff them and fuck with
them and you've got no window.
Just gentle public like nastiness
because they can guys what you guys do,
here's their way. I get a personal way.
If you're just blocking their path
where a normal person would go,
excuse me guys, because they're where
the walk guys walk cause it turns out,
oh shit.
But sometimes they don't have t luckily
benefit of the doubt right there.
They're in Times Square. They're
dealing with a lot of people.
There's just not time for the [inaudible]
circumstances I'm talking about in
just a thing like that.
The same way they put on their lights
to go through a red light just to get,
cause they don't want to wait
at the opportunistic like that.
Of course it's shower beings.
Human beings don't do well with
authority mixed with impunity.
So like a cop can say that to you and
nothing happens to them if there's no
repercussions and you have power
10 [inaudible] Guy Jimmy justice.
I had a job as a security guard for a
brief moment in time when I was like 19
years old and there was an us versus them
mentality between the security and the
people with the concert goers.
That was clearly evident.
One of the first days I was working
there, this guy, his name was Allie cat,
so to brand security and some dude
had stole one of the golf cards,
so the golf card, one of them
electric golf carts for security.
So they tackled this dude off the golf
cart and he smashes him in the head with
a fucking walkie talkie.
It's like a crazy fight with some drunk
asshole who's like violet and stole a
golf cart. Uh, that
was like the first day,
their first or second day there
on the job. I was like, oh, okay.
So this is what's going on. And it
became people trying to sneak booze,
integrate woods and then us.
And then so it was this us versus them
mentality and everybody was lying to you.
And that was the silliest job.
I'm doing security at a fucking
bill Cosby show. Literally,
I was doing security. I was taking
people's boobs and you know,
what did you let happen?
You could have stepped in and sucked
them talking about falling asleep on the
job. Hilarious. It's such a, you know,
it's such a simple little job. It's
easy. There's no criminals there.
There's no bank robbers.
There is no murders there.
That little situation of us versus
them with the liquor and them trying to
smuggle in pot and liquor.
Just that led to this huge fucking rift
between the security people and the way
they thought was funny because it's
too much of a human emotion in it.
That's something that should be a job
because even if you don't care if people,
when you're not working, you're trying
to get beer and weed into a concert.
It's just that these are your opponents
right now and they're trying to fuck
with you. Even though some of
you were like, you go like,
I don't care if you guys
smoke weed. You're like, no,
but I have to say you can't smoke
weed and then when they do it anyway,
like I just fucking said,
you can't smoke weed.
It's like testing your manhood almost.
It's a too much human emotion in
there versus on Netflix. I can't,
I bet that experiment will college
was that. It's like a famous story.
It's Princeton, the Princeton
prison or no, Stanford.
I'm still going to Stanford
prison experiment. You know,
I read something debunking the, yeah,
they said the methodology was all wrong
on it or something like it's not a legit
study.
They also said that people were doing
things just to end the study quickly
because they wanted to go home.
We did that in the movie though.
They broke that down. They showed that
side of it where they were like the,
they said, I guess the guy who made
the experiment said, yeah, it's a wash.
The end of it was like, it
wasn't actually good data,
but it was interesting and I do believe
that Stanford was the Stanford prison
experiment. Students pretended to be some
pretend to be criminals, San Pitocin,
and they started getting cars to
power positions. Got I came up.
The interesting things is that the
professor becomes like the warden,
he gets into it too, like
they cut that, they show,
they got it on video and stuff and he's
like walking around with his chest out
and he's all in. It's just people
get, they fall into these roles,
into these camps and the authority
goes to people's head. It may,
it creates a weird dynamic about how
many dickhead cops people have met.
Right. That's just a thing that happens,
but it also makes it very nice when
you run into friendly cops. Well,
that's trout. What a good dude.
It's almost like training the human
interaction so they're there when they act
like a Dick and people act a certain way
and they move and they get a little bit
nervous. It's like, oh, that's like
intoxicating and they're like, all right,
that feels good.
That power right there said about
no repercussions for your behavior,
the way you talking with d. You could
just do that with impunity. That's,
you just nailed it.
That's exactly what it is.
That's not a normal situation
for people. That's all.
I mean it's state verse business. If he
asked, here we go. You walk into some,
my Gosh, look, if you walk
into the apple store or you,
they can't do that because
you're a voluntary customer,
so if they treat you the wrong way,
there's a repercussion right there.
You're like, well, I'll walk out here
dark stores with the black dudes.
How their homeless camps now
[inaudible] at least
they're not shooting people,
but cell phones has become the great
equalizer because now you see cops there,
they're on it walking on eggshells. Dude,
pay out their cell phones
now and they're like,
what up bitch ass pussy
cop and the cops like,
well I guess I'm a bitch
ass pussy. You see the
[inaudible] is the battery
runs out on that cell phone.
I'm going to shoot you
in the stomach. Dude.
Did you see the video in New York where
they're throwing water on the cops and
the cops just aren't doing
shit? I Dunno. I think it was.
It might've been in Harlem. I say,
isn't it like a black
neighborhood in New York?
They're dumping water on the cops and
everyone's got a cell phone camera on them
and you know, in any other
period of time or today
beating the shit out of everyone.
They're throwing water balloons at him
and shit and they're just sitting there
like, we know I'm going to be in
the news tomorrow. I'm going to be,
you know what I mean?
Like I'll be a famous,
that cop definitely goes home that
night and like shadow above with two
nightsticks just practicing like the last
dragon fight that he was in that day.
[inaudible] she had a box
for two hours of homeowners.
Pour water on me. Here's
some water for you.
[inaudible] a lot of them have been on
the forest for 15 years, 20 years today.
They've just been doing things a certain
way for so long and I'm so close to
[inaudible]. Do you guys ever see
the seven five Oh yeah. Excellent.
[inaudible] you interviewed Him
Dad. Yeah, he's is he likable? Yeah.
Very nice guy. What's his name?
Michael Dowd. Is that my clo doubt?
Michael Dowd. I didn't see it. It's an
excellent documentary. It's doubt. Doubt,
doubt. Yeah. You know, he's great.
He's a really nice guy and he's super
open and honest about what happened in the
documentary. He's fucking compelling
shit. And you realize that.
How much of it was true when I think
he's not remorseful at all. What I find,
that's where I find unlikable. He's not
remorseful. I think he's remorseful.
He just look, he just has that
voice just doing coke all day long,
every day as a cop and you know, making
all this money and driving a corvette.
He was out of control
and he was on the, uh,
the area where he was the 75th
precinct, I think it's east New York,
Brooklyn at the height
of like the New York.
This was like the murder
neighborhood capitol. Like it was,
it was a wild team were in the chain
of shove a lot of those murders.
That's what I think is like
crazy. But like they were never,
they were never convicted of a
murder. Right. And there was no,
admittedly that he was cuddled.
He's like, let me, of course,
like talk about doing one
right. Yeah, never happened.
The whole thing is crazy,
but what it tells you,
I mean forget about pers are judgments
on, you know, the people that were in it.
What it tells you is that this can
happen to someone who just becomes a cop.
You get on the force.
If it's a bad force word like it was at
the time with him and he seen corruption
from day one. I mean, it was just like
he was roped into it. Like right away,
when you listen to his story,
it's pretty fucking compelling.
This is like the first day on
the job, like something happened.
They threw a guy off a
building or something like
that, but took it personally.
I don't remember. Yeah, but it was,
and then there's just that personality
chart that you could take. Yup.
You're like, I can just have them.
No one will know there's 50 gs here.
I could just take this home. And they're
like, oh, we didn't find anything.
It's very easy. It's very telling of the
personality. That becomes a cop though,
because they're not even
worried that people are getting,
it's amazing that no one whistleblowers
so much earlier than that because one
person comes in and goes, no guys,
we're supposed to be fucking
believing in this badge and what we,
you know what I mean? No. They
all go, what are we doing?
We good cups are bad cups. He goes, ever
Robyn? Drug dealers like, alright man,
I still do that with the
guys. She said, we'll do that.
I got a phone call and lost this fight
though. So I don't think that, honestly,
to be honest,
I have almost no problem
with cops skimming off the
top from drug dealer money.
What do you want me to fucking say?
We're just giving it to the government.
Why does the government get to have the
money and these cops who are putting
their wives, wait a minute. Not if
they're arresting people for drugs. Yeah.
Look,
if you're going to do that and you're
going to just ignore everyone else who
selling coke. Okay,
but if you're going to do that and
arrest people for selling coke,
then you're a criminal, then
you're like arrested. Yeah, that's,
that's the repercussion. I don't
have a, almost a moral issue with it.
If say if he found $50,000 only reported
40,000 put $10,000 in his pocket,
brought her home to his wife and kids,
I don't really have a
moral issue with that.
If he brought it home to just fucking
pay for is backed up like porn bill or
something because we just
brought him the fuck around Jay.
They won't let you go that long if you
want to get reinstated, there's fees.
If he got arrested, I wouldn't go,
Oh, poor fucking guy. I go, yeah dude,
that's the price you pay. You
committed a crime that that,
but from my personal perspective,
I don't think he's a piece of shit.
I don't think he's a bad person.
I think it's probably stupid if he doesn't
look the cycle of people and drugs is
never ending. It will go
on to the end of time.
The cycle of making drugs illegal and
propping up gigantic criminal enterprises
because of that is also
as old as we've had laws.
As long as we've had laws, vet
people breaking those laws.
And if those laws exist because someone
wants to control people's behavior in a
way that people don't want, folks
are going to find a work around.
But no drugs are [inaudible] empowers
the Mexican cartels right now.
And some Mexican cartels
are a huge source of,
of fear for people that live in the
border towns is a huge source of fear for
people that are forced to
be in communities and it's
propped up because drugs
are illegal. Nobody seems
to want to recognize that.
It's one of those ugly things about
being a human that like people want drugs
and you can't tell them they
can't have what they want. Yeah.
Especially since immigration became such
a huge thing that everyone's talking
about and that's like the biggest
part of it that no one talks about.
It's like the violence and it's like,
well there's people on this side
of this line who want the drugs.
There's people on this side of the line
who have the drugs and even with all the
shit you're doing, they're still
trading them to each other.
So do you really think maybe we
should just let them do it? We're in,
but here's the thing. We don't want
anybody to do it rightly so. I mean, look,
we know you don't want anybody
run around doing heroin.
Nobody gets through that and goes,
it was amazing. It was my best,
one of my best moments in life was
when I was addicted to heroin. Yeah.
But even if you do it one time, I bet
it's pretty fucking dope. It's amazing.
Just one hard too to let it
go. Once you've experienced it,
it's probably fucking incredible. Lenny
Bruce had some crazy description of it,
about something about being hugged
by an angel or something like that.
Michael Stephano, who died a few
years ago, New York comic had a joke.
He was like, he was like,
you know, great heroin is,
it's like taking a bath
in a pool full of kittens.
Metzker Metzker had that joke
about it where he says, uh,
when the families of people go, he goes,
I don't understand why he would do heroin.
He's got a family that loves him and
kids who look up to them and love him,
like, why would he do heroin? He goes, oh,
I want to tell that family like
you're just so close to the answer.
Heroin is better than all those
things. That is hilarious.
Yeah, but I mean, I don't think people
should do it, but if you make it illegal,
it's not, they're not going to stop
doing it. The question would be,
would people do more
of it if it was legal,
if you could just go to a drug store the
same way you go to a liquor store and
the drug store was actually a drug store
where you could just go buy coke and
they might, well, look in La, I do think
more people are smoking weed for sure.
Since we became legal like I, that'd be
my guess. I don't know what the date is.
I'm sure that's fine, but,
but even if that's the case,
I don't know if that's the answer because
let's say even slightly more people
did heroin. Hold on. Wait, less
people got murdered. What's that year?
Heroin. What? Jamie? Just
[inaudible] more. Do people smoke
weed more since legalization? Well,
that was the most hilarious.
Not Remember when we were talking about
it's gotten cheaper. It's easier to get,
it's better. It's more
fun. It's in candy form.
It's in fucking 1818 year old is more
likely to definitely give it a try versus
maybe would have. When I had gotten weed
for the first time I was 17 years old,
I had to have my uncle Raymond buy
it for us. He skimmed off the bag.
I remember and he brought us a fucking
dime bag and me and my two best friends,
we smoked a joint before we were going
to see system of a down and cubis and Mr
Bungle at snow court, Puerto Rican. So
your uncle like two years older than you,
one of those deals. Is that
why he did that? But to me bro,
we the night before we want it
to smoke and it took us, we,
there was no way to get it.
We were trying to find weed for so long
because we weren't in that world the
first time you go to get weed,
if you could just go to a store and
pick it up and it's fun and you know,
it's like I'm at a mall. I
mean, yeah, I mean astronomical.
But you know, I love weed, so
I'm on Hayden. It's great. Well,
it was hard to get on the east coast.
It's just trickier out here still.
But since the nineties once the
past, those laws from medical,
everybody had a medical card.
It's not hard to get it.
All the doctors were extremely
unscrupulous and their prescriptions.
So everybody's had weed out here since
the fucking nineties yeah, like strong,
strong, easy to get women now.
They really don't give a shit.
If you smoke like outside, you could
smoke a true smoker like a cigarette now.
And none of those. No, I don't
think you get smoking outside.
It's still think you have to be
indoors. I think smoking outside,
the problem is other people can smell
it and you're not supposed to do that.
I think in Denver it's like nine feet
from an entrance. You can smoke weed.
I smoke vape. I mean everywhere
inside of a movie theater.
As I'm walking through a mall, I go to
the bathroom at the airport and I smoke.
Yes. That's what ethnics do.
They challenge everyone by being big
in Alpha in a place like Starbucks.
I'm buying anything. Yeah, I'm smoking.
What definitely keeps me around
so we can be racist. I go,
what do you mean my dentist is black,
Blue Shit. Black dancers to be hilarious.
Gold teeth. Snoop's got
diamond, lower teeth.
Now what am snoop Dogg these diamond
stud or like them creative Donald Grill
diamond things. He's in this video.
He's driving around on his Instagram in
a Lamborghini with diamond lower teeth
50 years ago. Right. I love it. 50 years
old. Diamond teeth. He's living it,
man. Oh, for sure. He doesn't give a fuck.
He spends most of his time getting
furious video games online. Does he? Yeah,
he just yells about Madden like
[inaudible] for a minute. Right.
He was commentating like, uh,
with your wife or your neighbor.
They would drink and watch the
fight. So he was drinking like tango,
rained smoking joints and
watch all the fights. Oh,
these wackos tough because what it was
was there was some commentary that he did
just independently on one fight and it
was so hilarious because he's so animated
and screaming and yelling about this
fight that, uh, everybody thought like,
wow,
wouldn't it be great if there was an
option to watch the snoop Dogg commentary
on demand? You could click over to
the snoop dog version. That's right.
And it was probably, I don't
know, I've never watched it,
but I assume it was fucking horrific.
Oh, let's go go one north south.
He's got his diesel in this middle.
[inaudible] yeah, just the, uh, I
guess they got bored with it there.
You got bored doing it or
something. I Dunno. It stopped.
Maybe Snoop's fucking busy. He doesn't
have time to be doing that volunteer.
He's like Mike Tyson too, in the sense
that I just, I remember when he was like,
scary. I hear this. Let's
listen to this mother fucker.
Mother fucking ne. Oh, that's
right. It was Colby. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Yeah. Tyrell show up, N***a.
[inaudible] he thought it
was called [inaudible].
He thought it was called because
he thought it was cool, but it was
a man from a completely different
part of the world. Yep. Yeah.
Fuck Donald Trump. That is hilarious.
Thought it was coldly. That's so fun.
Holy Shit. He was getting some
booze the other night, Huh? Dude.
DACA hears touching. Yep. When those
people are booing [inaudible] emotion,
dude,
emotion. You want to get the emotion
out of people, whether it's good or bad,
it doesn't fucking matter.
They want to see him fight
and they want to see him lose.
He's going, he'll, he went, he'll
listen. He's a good guy. I'm telling you.
I know that guy.
I've met him outside of this crazy thing
that he's doing and this crazy thing
that he's doing came
about when he was, uh,
like on the verge of getting cut
and people didn't like to style.
And so he went hard. He'll, when he
fought Damien mind, he went hard. Yeah.
We'll chill to dissimilar thing. Shell
wasn't the big mouth guy back in the day.
No, he was not.
Yeah. And he just made a decision one
day that he's going to be that dude.
It wasn't right at the Anderson Fife
fucking great marketing decision. Smart.
Very smart. And Colby too. It's
like, oh, but also Colby, he,
something happened as well. He's really
exciting. The, that last fight, Ooh,
that last fight was incredible dude.
Um, but yeah, call me is definitely,
it's contrived.
I appreciate the effort.
Um, but he's not effective.
See the thing about it being contrived
is it makes it obvious that he's putting
on a show. But the thing is that
putting on a show is fucking,
he's ruthless.
He fucks with people's heads legitimately
like they do not want to lose to him.
And then when you get inside the
AUC gun, he's really fucking good.
Like really far. I didn't realize
how good he was until the fight.
You see the amount of strikes at that guy,
no volume. And then he's an unbelievable
wrestling. It's a really, really,
really tough matchup for anybody.
And Colby is, it is a, uh, you know,
an act and it is pro wrestling. He
puts on the Trump hat and people,
I mean people just see that hat and they
lose their fucking mind and he trolls
half the country and it's a
similar thing with the other,
with when businesses do
it, I'm going like guys,
don't be rubes like it's very obvious
that it's just an act and if you're a fan
of mixed martial arts,
you have to appreciate the fact that some
guys are taking chances and trying to
generate interest. You can,
every guy can't just be put on a suit
and be straight for showcased and I
respect my show
at some point. You want to go
a little story? Yeah, yeah.
I mean he makes juice here,
but the bottom line is we put all that
shit aside and just look at what he's
doing. You look at it, he's doing
it like that guy's extraordinary.
Like the fact that he could do that to
Robbie Lawler completely shut down his
off offense and just put a beating
on him. Just stay on top of him.
Never give them any air.
I never give him any air.
The pace is smothering and it's
striking. Looked really good. Very good.
I mean very, very, very takes
a shot. Takes the shot. Great.
And his cardio is off
the fucking charts. Yeah,
it's a that, that whole one 70 right now.
That whole division is
looking crazy right now. Yeah.
Nate Diaz being back in the mix and
a Mazda, Mazda and Nate seems like,
just like if you're a fan of just like
if you're from a poor neighborhood that
is like the superstar match.
I like where I grew up.
It's just shitty like environment.
It's like that was like the perfect who
hood rat fucking guys who are going to
talk. They're going to go
in there and fight it. God, it's
so awesome. I love so much money.
That's why it's going to be so giant.
While it was cool that Dana White at
the post-fight press conference he got
asked, cause you know
he had famously said,
I think once that Nate Diaz doesn't
move the needle or something like along
those lines negotiated. But he, he
basically said, he goes, I think Nate,
besides, uh, Connor and Ronda Rousey
is like about as big a star as MMA has.
Like, they did crazy good
numbers. Everyone, the arena
was going nuts for him.
He was,
he walked out yesterday or Saturday night
when he walked out the fucking place.
Roared,
I mean as loud as anybody as
loud as any main event person,
whether it's Steve Bay or DC.
Nate Diaz got the biggest roar and
then he had a great performance,
I believe in leading up to it.
People were talking about Nate coming
back more than they were talking about the
heavyweight title. I don't think,
I don't think some people in the UFC
realize how big a star he really is.
I think they thought that the Conor
fight, Connor was the big star.
Nate beat him. The Conor
won the second fight.
Connor still remains the big superstar.
I think Nate is equally as big as star,
but I think that Scott is, Connor's
maybe an old worldwide's like,
but in America, Nate Diaz is a giant
fucking star. Not as big as Connor,
but a tier below maybe
the credit Connor levels.
You have to say he won the two
fights. I mean, if you take,
who would you rather be
in the two fights? I mean,
he choked Connor out face down in the
first one and then had like a raise our
clothes. Unbelievable.
Great fight the second time.
So I mean he comes out of that
looking pretty good. Yeah.
But I think it's a testament
to how popular Connor is
because that's the fucking
Connor shine and it was a dance and
Nate brought it and Nate has that story.
The one on one fight. It's
turning into this star button.
If he never danced with Connor,
would he be that big to know?
I don't know know that cause Nate
was, but that's him for years before.
He's always, he's the fucking
like do the double middle fingers.
Like there's so many moments where
you could, where you're like,
I get goosebumps thinking about nasal
fine. That's your favorite part.
When he's like, these are the
fingers that take [inaudible].
He said fuck you a,
you're in the triangle.
You got in the triangle and fucking best
him double fingers and flexed and he
was losing that fight too. Yeah.
And then he tried was grassed.
Oh and then yeah. Then the Donald
Serone fight third round, they come out.
They're so fucking good dude.
Nate's, once again, it's just,
you don't have to be a mixed martial
arts fan and you got to be a human and go
like that's a fucking fighter. That is
something that everyone wants to watch.
I hope he makes it an actual belt
cause he's saying he's got the baddest
motherfucker in the game belt.
Then who wants to defend, you know,
who wants to be next to challenge for
the baddest motherfucker in the game belt
and a, I love that. I love that.
That's his marketing strategy.
He should really legitimately get a
belt made up bad as motherfucker in the
game. I'm sure the old UFC belt, UFC
isn't using that old belt anymore.
I'm like you have a bat, UFC baddest
mother fucker in the game belt and just,
just, just change the
outside a little bit.
Was He smoking weed for real
in the uh, in open workouts?
Is he going to get in trouble for no,
no, no. It's totally legal in California.
And when you task,
do you have to literally be high while
you're fighting for you to test positive?
You saw it dropped it all way, way down.
Well but so many people use it to sleep.
So many people use it for pain relief.
Particularly with CBD when it's
one to one. This is like these are,
these are one to one THC and CBD and
they think that it's actually more
effective for both.
It actually calms you down a little
bit with the CBD along with the THC.
So it may,
it might actually alleviate some anxiety
that's associated with getting to high
when that makes sense. Cause that's
how it comes in the plant, right.
Is like both parts. Well yeah.
Yeah, I guess, except it's,
I think CBD, it doesn't come as
big. So to get one in one, you know.
Okay. You smoke a joint, how much
CBD you're smoking. I have no idea.
I have no question. Do you even get
CBD when you just smoke a joint?
You have never heard of CBD until it
wasn't in the joint anymore by itself.
Well t THC is one of many,
many cannabinoids, right?
Isn't there like 19 of them or something
crazy like that? Is that what it was,
Jamie 18 yeah, that's
a, okay. I don't know.
I think the plant itself is what's magic.
It's a crazy goddamn plant that we're
finally getting to appreciate and it's
still, there's a lot of places where
you still have to buy hemp from Canada.
I'm like large scale hemp production
hasn't really caught on with a good
percentage of his country cause I used
to be like one of one of the major crops
that people would grow. You can make
clothes out of it, you could eat it.
It makes this shit called hempcrete.
It's like this insanely durable concrete
that's made with hemp to fucking nutty
plant man. It really is like
the stock of a hemp tree.
Like got my friend Todd McCormick had
one sitting on his desk once and you pick
it up. It's like, what is this from
another world? It's hard like hard,
but light is Balsa Wood.
Lightest Styrofoam. Wait,
does that have any sense than weed?
No, no. I mean there's just the,
the differences. Hamp is not psychoactive.
It's like a psychoactive form of
the same sort of a kind of plants.
But regular marijuana also is hemp,
right? Because what hemp is is the fibers.
So what we're using to get
high is the buds, right?
The stems and all the
other leaves and shit.
But that fiber of the plant itself
is insanely durable and really light.
And that's the shit they turn into clothes
and to string and to all this and to
paper canvas. The first canvas was
made with hemp, all that stuff.
That's why it was can that then the word
cannabis or canvas comes from cannabis.
That's, that's why it's called canvas.
But they did everything with him.
But it's just hard to do, man.
They just have to beat it down like
these slave labor most of the time.
And then the 1930 some dude came up with
something called a decorticator in is
a, a machine where you can
effectively process the hemp fiber.
And that's when they started going
crazy with the reefer madness shit.
It was all an economic
slave shop, jazz and jazz.
They already had, everybody was
already doing it. I mean, that was,
that was something that was a
normal thing with people. It was a,
it wasn't until they decided to make
it illegal that it became this weird
fucking thing that nobody could, uh,
nobody could do something that
they'd been doing for so long before.
Where are they made there?
Aren't they making mushrooms and
acid legal somewhere, by the way?
They were [inaudible] fucking heavyweight
champion. The world just called.
Sorry. Oh Shit. Name-Dropping yeah, he
looks good. One fuck would a crazy fight.
Wow. Did I read that somewhere?
They're going to be their donut. Maybe.
I mean, that guy who's like a
rocky movie. Just the change. Yeah,
the turn and that fight was so crazy.
Look, DC's my very good friend.
I love him to death. I
love that guy. It's hard.
It's hard watching a friend
that you really love a get
his ass kicked and that's
what happened. He was looking great.
Yeah, he was a really great look. He's,
he's an awesome person,
man. I love that dude.
And doing commentary with him
is the most hilarious, fun time.
He's such a good guy. He's
great commentary. He's very,
very articulate and smart. He's one
of the best that does it, Andy. Uh,
yeah, dude, it sucks.
It's just you see that,
you see the pain on his face when he
loses a fight. He does not like losing.
He is not, it doesn't, but neither
the steeper, you know what I mean?
And this is what, that's
what it's all about.
Those two guys I have deep respect
for Steve Bay too. I've been,
I was saying forever that
I thought it was fucked up,
that he was not going to get a title
shot, not going to get a rematch.
Instead they were going to have him
fight Brock Lesnar. I'm like, look,
the fight is supposed to be Steve Bay.
He was the most successful heavyweight
ever won four title fights,
won the title and then defended it three
times. No one's ever done that before.
Right? So that was the giant in the
guys he beat. We're fucking really good.
And it's not just like you gave it
prime, it'd be one thing if you said,
you know, uh,
he got knocked out in the first round so
we're going to give the first crack to
this number one contender who's
like on a, on a tear or something.
But to just say Brock Lesnar,
because this is a big, it was,
it was the most naked example of this is
just for pay per view buys is that kind
of sucks for steep bay. Yeah. It sucks
for Steepbank and I'm glad it didn't,
didn't happen. I'm glad that
Steve Pay got his chance.
Cause just out of respect for
the sport and respect for the,
the true champions of the sport, like did
some matter what marketability or not,
that guy is the best champion
that's ever been in the game.
He's the best heavyweight
champion of all time.
So like to not what recognize that and
not like that should be a big deal.
No, I agree with you.
That should be the fight.
But the money of the Brock Lesnar fight
would have been so immense that if
you're a company that makes entertainment,
this is why it's kind of
like UFC in some ways.
There's a marriage of entertainment
and of sport because debate,
I mean the people are the ones who are
buying the paper views and showing for
it. So if more of them,
what's good for the goose is good for the
gander because you get Brock Lesnar to
come on a card, you get massive,
massive eyes on it and then you get,
every time you do that, there's
a percentage of people who stay
fans and become hardcore fans and tell
people about it. And then there's,
there's real value there
for everybody. So, um, yeah,
but the heavyweight championship of
the world is supposed to be the most
procedures and you don't see that in any
other sport where a guy will be coming
off a loss before years removed. You know,
test positive for steroids and then
just get a title shot. Um, and you know,
that's the way of putting it. Yeah,
that is a good, very good point.
I what I want to see more
even than the DC thing,
I want to see Francis and [inaudible]
to cause Francis and [inaudible] just
destroyed Cain and junior dos Santos who
if you guys were met just a few years
ago, those were the guys,
Kim Call Him God zealous,
the heavyweight division and
he just destroyed both of them.
He looks like he got his confidence
back. He looks at, you know,
like I want to see that
rematch. Yeah. I'm a,
I'm terrified for everybody who gets
in the octagon every time he fights
somebody. I'm like, cause I remember,
I remember I still have like shell shock
for watching Alster Overeem get hit
with that left hook.
I remember that was the hardest
knockout I've ever seen ever.
No one's gonna survive that. It
looked like the back of Ellisor.
Overeem's head touched his
ankles. I was like, no one,
everyone's going out from that. Everyone's
going out cold. That's the payload.
The heavyweights.
You just have to like have so much
respect because it's like holy shit dude,
like you're getting in there and it's
just like at any moment you're just gone.
I'd rather fight a heavyweight than like
135 pound or though just to be hitting
a thousand times in the
head. That's the punch bro.
That should be a tee shirt
like just the silhouette.
It's interesting you say
that with the DC we're like,
I just know him and he's like as little
as we know Mickey Gall as much as like
we've been friends with him
for a short amount of time.
Even like when he fights there's some
different like stakes on it but as a buddy
you're like Tommy and you must see that
a lie and you're calling it like you
can't really put my chart for me when
cowboy fights I root against this bar.
Actually that was really hard
when Brendan was widening.
I was really hard cause I'm real tight
with him. We're really good friends.
And when, when he wasn't really doing
it anymore, it was, he was still in it,
but he wasn't really like 100% in,
he was thinking about other things he
was thinking about when he gets out.
It wasn't, it didn't have the same focus
and intensity and trainings used to.
That's hard. That's not the
sport to do that. And you know,
it's hard when whenever you
thinking about getting out, get out,
get out because there's people that
aren't thinking about getting out and you
got to think about what we
were talking about earlier.
Like Mike Tyson is prime angry
at everything. Like if you,
you're thinking about getting out and
you've run in front of a guy like that,
you know, or a girl like that.
There's this female kickboxers
that are like that too.
They're just fucking vicious man. And
they're waiting. You think you're,
you're half in half out thinking about
cheerleading, wham Shin to the face.
You know,
you gotta be all saying at the end for
anything could've been beaten by a woman.
Yes. Am I following you correctly?
The fucking highest levels of any
combat sport. You have to be all in.
I don't think. I don't think
that's something you could dabble in.
Yeah. It's a hard thing though,
because I think in MMA, you know,
Luckily Brendan is a, you
know, podcast or comedian.
I think a lot of other guys,
they don't have the same,
but they could do other stuff like Tyron
Woodley's wrapping Tyron Woodley as
businesses. I know he's doing
something with CBD. I know he's got a,
he did a record with Wiz Khalifa.
I know he does a lot of TMZ stuff.
He's a funny dude.
I think you have to become the
[inaudible] look tyrants champion,
smart champion though. It's like he
has a huge name was, but he's still,
he's working. See, he lost
his title. That was gone,
but yet he's still doing
all these other things.
Of course, but I think it's easier
when you, when you have that name,
you're a former UFC champion.
I think that alone will probably sort
of set you up as long as you're not an
idiot for the rest of your life. But
they're guys that never get to that very,
very top. And if they don't sort of
set themselves up for afterwards,
they're going to, you know, when you
think about getting out, you're like,
Shit Dude. The reason they
take those fights there was,
what was that one documentary
I saw where the guy was like,
you've got like crazy brain injuries
and, and his family was just like, dude,
don't take another fight.
And he still had to take it.
He's had to pay the bills. And it was
just like, there was just no other option.
He was like barely making money at a gym.
So that's the thing where it's like
is a sport where you're all in.
And then once it kind of shit hits the
fan, I said it reminds me of comedy.
Cause like it takes a minimum five to
10 years to figure out if you're gonna
even be good enough to do
it professionally. Right.
And then at that point
it's your whole life.
So this way university people
quitting, nobody quit school.
You see a lot of people that maybe they
started like 20 and like by 30 they're
10 years in and if it's
not working out for you,
you took the 10 years when you were
supposed to be figuring out where the
trajectory of like everyone you knew
from high school figured out a job,
got a house, got mad or
whatever, you know, age that now,
because you could do comedy for six
months and have a youtube video that makes
you a a where you can make 25 grand on
a Sunday doing one Sunday show at an
Improv. But have you watched that
guy's youtube channel? That's rare.
That doesn't happen too often.
I think it's rare that there's,
you know guys who are doing comedy for
six months that are making six months.
Sure, sure, sure. The extreme
example. Yeah, for sure.
It should mean thing does.
It doesn't. I'm just saying,
I'm just making a point that it's not
really, there's so many alternatives now,
but even with food, like Lewis said, like
I agree technically in like the, the,
the growth of someone
like 10 years in, they,
they got their legs under
them like good nick.
Now they can start figuring out
what their is going to be exactly.
And find their market. That's what
you become like a honed great comic.
Hopefully, you know,
but like you can get popular and have
to work into the pressure of a soul deaf
theater it three years in the comedy.
That is crazy. It's crazy. I couldn't,
I couldn't Charlie my possibly
imagine that doing Charlie Murphy a
d d did it even more insane way.
He was famous first and then he
became an open miker. That's,
that's gotta be challenging.
Lot sold out shows all he practices
only is doing giant shows right.
Where everybody's coming to see him and
Don l and all these other Connell's like
killer by the way. He's, yeah,
he's going up with like monsters in the
Chappelle show. Right. Jeremy Pivot.
Hello Jeremy Pivot and
stuff. He's Brandon.
Brandon was a star when he started
doing comedy. He was already known,
very know Sue's already
known as a UFC fighter. Yeah.
But what Charlie Murphy did was do like
these sold out fucking shows and he was
practicing. Yeah. Like
I mean I don't think,
I don't know how much time he spent before
he went ups on stage the first time,
like knowing that he was
going to do stand up.
I think it was also famous
from the Chappelle show and
from two of the greatest
comedy sketches ever done that Dave
Chappelle was acting out for them and they
were so funny. And so the is visitation
fee. He's going to be fucking,
so any expectation when you go in is like,
I'm going to see like the
greatest comedian in the
country and he's doing like
his third set that he's
ever done. That's crazy.
Comedy is the only art form that you
practice in front of the audience.
There's nothing else or
you ha and you have to,
the only way to do it is practice in
front of painters apartment in Washington.
Everyone else gets a master of their
craft by themselves in a fuck, whatever.
It's, it can be mixed
martial arts in a gym.
It could be in a garage or
in a band, whatever it is.
Everyone else gets to figure it out.
But we from moment one is this naked
thing where like, all right, well let me,
and it's so douchey. I think
back to the first time,
like what fucking type of asshole would
even give it a shot the first time?
It's like going, hey, I just
wrote this song today and they go,
well fucking sucks. I'm not going to
clap for that terrible. You just wrote
next. They wouldn't, they would just
go at the end of it, they'd go, yeah,
you played a song, you can
make a song in a vacuum.
I mean you can just guys who have created
the most amazing fucking songs and
then they let you play them or let you
listen to them and you're like, whoa.
Like how long have you
guys been working on this?
Like if you have friends that are in
a band and they're like four months,
like holy shit. They can do it all.
It put it together from start to finish
without anybody else involved other than
the producers in them. We can't do
that. No we can't. Anybody tries.
It's crazy. Did somebody to,
somebody tried to do a studio stand
up album? I didn't somewhat know.
Well there was this special Carmichael
directed draw Michaels and that's right.
No, no audience con
show. Yeah, hang on. No,
that room just got quiet. Everyone
trying to not shit under Michael now.
You know, I was just doing question
of his audience. I was quite confused.
I was like, it was confusing. But what
are you doing? You're drew Michael.
You're a young comic. 10 years in HBO.
You're like, I gotta deal with fuck,
I gotta do it. Drunk HOK wants
to produce it and no audience.
Let's see what happens.
You could feel anything other than weird
doing standard that you used to doing
in front of an audience to know audience.
You would be fighting feeling weird
the entire time you were talking.
Cause you know you're,
there's no one there.
So you just taught me into
a camera. You gotta tell.
So there's two audiences watching to be
honest with you, needs a laugh track.
The reason laugh tracks exist on TV
shows is because the the audience,
sometimes they just need to be told die.
Here's the moment they don't go Caribbean
enthusiasm doesn't have a laugh track.
It's one of the funny shows them all
the time. I don't know if you need the,
it's not the laugh track, it's what's
the energy that creates just that.
You're watching like this before,
like you're part of something.
Everyone's like, you're supposed to be
laughing along with them. Like laughing.
If a guy, if, if,
if drew Michael came to you in person
and started saying those funny things to
you, like with that tone you'd
be like, this is uncomfortable.
Even the funny thing you took away
from me, dude, you feel weird doing,
you feel we already hit a punch on the go.
If there's like just you and him
as too, it's too intimate, right?
You're not even,
but it's not a you when you do in standup
like you and one person, I couldn't,
right. Who the fuck would
ever talk like that?
That whole works in front of large people.
So you taking something that only
works in front of groups of pms.
Do you ever go to a convenience store
and the guy working there is looking at
you like you're not gonna but why are you
saying it like this? This is so weird.
So I says, I says comedy
is not just talking.
It is using the pauses and using the
timing and using the moments where they're
supposed to laugh. There's so much
more to it than just sang the jokes.
You know that that's the
side of what, where you go.
It's like I just don't as an experiment,
I get it as like a youtube video.
I get it. But as as
your first big special,
I would want there to be an audience
there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Probably upset.
But I think Daraja is just a creative guy
and he had this idea and they just ran
with it. I heard he wants
to do it for himself.
Where do you see as the disease one
where Spike Jones on stage and the whole
time and they filmed it where Lee could
see like the back behind the stuff.
People like sweeping people
mulling around in the back.
I found it distracting
six strangely distracting.
Just I didn't understand why
that would be a good idea.
You don't have to get like you happened
to be filming all we up in the film as
he's working out here and you see a
bunch of people in the backyard but it
doesn't matter. The material's
good. You'll enjoy this.
This is a fucking scratch. You're
intentionally making it with concepts.
If you want of concept to the thing or
concept like kind of bookend the show,
like the show. It seems like it's all
like, Hey, look over here to be like,
I really didn't have like a an hour.
I'm super happy with, I'm not even,
I haven't seen the material of it
to know. I'm not saying as he's,
it's not a good hour. I just feel
like when you're throwing flour,
I would want less fluff to draw, to draw,
to like, hey, listen to these jokes.
Like please don't pay attention that like
we have the first ever overhead three
d camera like on the shot like
Jones. So I think you don't get it.
I think it's one of those
things where it's like, hey man,
I'd love it if you directed
it. And he'd be like, okay,
but I want to do something different.
Right. And then you're like, I trust you.
You're a master at what you do. I'm a
master when I do, let's collaborate.
And I get it. It was like, um,
when, uh, Steve Jobs, he, the,
the first apple logo,
he just paid $250,000 for and the
deal was he didn't get any revisions.
He got to like have a conversation
about what he wanted to feel.
And then this weird fucking artist
went and created the logo and was like,
here it is. And that's that.
Hmm. Okay. That's a bad deal.
Maybe Steve Jobs is not the business
man we imagined because a lot of money,
if you, he trusts it each may or may not
use your fucking desires. He to see it
[inaudible] paint Drexciya sketch.
He was going to do thousand
dollars not even successful yet.
We don't even have a logo that
people using $50 and if I like it,
can you create it? You create a logo
for my company. What's it called? Apple.
Yeah, that Bitch Woo.
She took a quarter mill and
bang that out in six minutes.
Fucking thing to divides this
country more than right. Left.
It might be android versus iPhone. Yeah,
but people aren't like a boycott and
businesses over it. No, they're not.
But that people look down on people
with android phones. They sure do.
They're less time. That's it.
It's just one of those things.
It's like if you have an iPhone you're
in and if you have an android phone,
you're on that other fucking
team. The bare minimum.
If you don't have an iPhone, you, you're
a fucking loser. That's what it is.
A guy for years and I used to,
I used to be one of the guys,
what's the big difference?
Who gives a shit?
And then I got an iPhone
and I was like, oh,
it's the differences. Just the
way your fingers, I don't know.
I'm going from one piece,
one thing to the next.
If you're opening up a
tax or going to a phone,
everything is just very seamless and
it's smooth and it feels very natural and
very nice. And android because somebody,
different people use that
sort of android platform.
It's always clunky and
it's not exactly the same,
so it never feels as smooth once you
get used to your iPhone. That's that.
And Yeah, I agree. I know very
successful people that stick by Android,
the newest android phones are
pretty fucking smooth. If you,
if you picked up like um,
um, galaxies, whatever,
that's like a galaxy s 10 does
those a smooth fucking phone man,
those things are as good as anything.
There's a bunch of phones now on the,
the side of android that rival
or are better than iPhones.
Some of the technologies, a hit
10 the note 10 that just came out.
Is there one that's not android or
iPhone that's like dope that people just
don't know about. That's like their
operating system, which is really weird.
It's like, yeah, you have three operating
systems. You have a, you have iPhones,
you have android, and there's still a
few people that have windows phones,
believe it or not blackberry.
Who the fuck uses that?
[inaudible] Thompson. I
think that's a joke. Well,
I think that's a gag. If I text him and
he goes blue, he's got a fucking iPhone,
pretends to not have a fucking real phone
or he's got multiple phones. Pageants,
fucking phony asshole. I talked to
him that one time. He does have it,
but he doesn't use it. Oh,
okay. Yeah, he's got it.
I think it was a joke though. Okay. I
think he really did miss those little w.
If you had a blackberry back in the day,
the thing that texting people you knew
where everything was buttons where you
can text pretty quick, that little ball
would break. It was so annoying. Yeah,
that thing would break, but uh,
the difference between that and
an iPhone is pretty substantial,
but the difference between iPhones and
android is not substantial anymore.
But don't you like [inaudible]? It's
pretty fucking [inaudible] iPhone.
I can't go back. I just know it. I
don't want to relearn a new phone.
I sat down and [inaudible] phone.
Now since Steve Jobs is gone,
that iPhone is catching up
on the technology to android.
The Android's like getting a lot of
things. You go look on my iPhone does now.
Some of those android goes,
but we've had two generations of that
era would be that they wait until the
technology is out and all the bugs are
knocked out of it and then they give you
a superior version of it. Yeah.
That's the argument. I mean, look,
it's the most successful company in the
fucking history, the known universe.
They have its shit. Fuck tons of cash.
I can't believe they didn't get
like the folding phone first.
I don't think that thing is worth
a fuck. I couldn't even guess.
It looks like it's weird making it fatter
or gummy. How to just give me this.
This is a good shape. You folks
stopped. They just constantly,
we've got to figure out how to extend
a brick. Roll it up. Like a little,
like a little fortune cookie worried
about is the Elon Musk thing.
The neurolink you hearing about that?
I'm not sure what the next
step to integrating computers
with your fucking brain
that's it's going to happen. Right?
If it's not this Elon Musk's thing doesn't
do that, then the next thing we'll,
but the ultimate goal is going to be,
we're going to have pieces in our body.
One thing, some computer, what the
word of like merging with the the body.
Yeah. Symbiotically Cyborg.
Cyborg. The child Cyborg. Yeah,
but that's true too. [inaudible] that's
what, that's what I was thinking about.
The singularity is what they
think would be the ultimate, uh,
technological innovation that
radically chance forms mankind.
And they moved that number around
and I think the singularity,
they think for artificial intelligence.
There was a symposium in New York a few
years back that Ari and I and Duncan
Trussell went to.
It was like the 20 I think it was like
2045 that's when they think they think at
2045 these things are going to go
alive and there'll be robot just like x
mocking that type people
walking around with us.
Oh for sure.
I mean I think I heard part
of the conversation you
had with the Elon Musk and
it was one of the most interesting
things because for a while I was going,
yeah dude, if you just put your phone
down, people don't really give a shit.
You go to the supermarket. People
aren't arguing about politics,
but eventually what's going to happen
is the phones are going to be in our
fucking brains and you're never gonna
be able to put the phone down and it's
going to be,
that's the world we live in where we
are just at war and that's where it's
fucking scary. That's what, I don't know.
[inaudible] jump in too quick too.
Hasn't already been like a whole bunch
of like self driving car accidents.
Terrible things happen. More human
accidents. Yeah, it's better.
Is it more human accidents per amount of
cars though? You know what I'm saying?
Like self driving cars. Really A,
you're not supposed to just sit there.
You supposed to hold on to the wheel.
I keep a hand on the wheel. It makes you
do that. You can't just uh, drive it.
It [inaudible] you can't
just sit back. It needs you to be engaged.
Like the little Duvall who just takes
videos of him like taking a nap and
smoking. Joe, what's out the
window? He's not involved at all.
So you get that like blocked where
the sensors like to take 'em all calm.
Assuming it's a sensor type,
is there anything that you can do
that's actually like a uh, iPhone mount?
Like a cell phone mount.
It sits on the handle and it
keeps pressure on the handle.
So the handle thinks that you're holding
onto the handle and you have your
iPhone robots an iPhone colder. So
they sell it as an iPhone holder.
But really what it is is something
that squeezes on the handle,
but they can't sell it as that
because that would be illegal.
It should be illegal.
It's pretty God damn good.
That thing that eventually drive shit
eventually I way more trust auto-drive.
I trust them to be able to come up
with the technology where they have
everything on perfect grids where we
all get in our cars and the absolute
fastest way for us to get from point a
to point B is already mapped out traffic,
all that shit that that's not that
crazy. I feel like that has to be within,
you know, 2030 year changes lanes
and everything. Oh yeah. Yeah.
It changes lanes.
Did it blow your mind the first
time you were on highway where those
[inaudible] that's common. All
that's coming [inaudible] never suck.
Your Dick would probably just give you
the experience in a chip while your click
3d Hologram lady appears and
starts bone feels like it's real,
but nothing's there. Whitney
Houston, your celebrities.
Remember how they made the future in
eighties movies though where the Dick
Sucking car would actually be like
a hose would come out of the ground.
That would be the field.
Look at the a mouth hose.
Would you really trust that mouth?
Always with your cock and what?
I want to wait until the third
or fourth version. I watched,
I watched total recall recently,
which is like, you know the new one,
the old one and got to that total recall.
The one a the running man. Oh Wow.
And it was like when he was
holding the girl hostage,
she was in the house like let's
look up what flights are right.
And it's just such obvious like Atari
graphics on the screen and at the year
2050 the music that really has good
ideas of what the future's going to be.
Even minority report when they're moving
stuff around on the screen. Like maybe,
maybe someday, but no one's
done anything where you go, wow,
that would be amazing if that was that.
Was it sort of the apple thing though,
is it?
Apple tries to make their stuff live up
to what they made like 1950 space movies
being everything's like very like metal
metallic and sleek looking like the
Gattica the uniform package. I'll
do that. Apple is a great company.
They really are. But when you open
up an iPhone or an apple product,
the packaging, they, it
has like an air thing.
We're in lifts naturally and it's
all based off the experience.
Like when you open it, you, you go, I've
never opened another product like this.
And if they do that on purpose and
it's this subconscious thing that they
fucking put into your mind and
that's why you go, dude, just,
I don't know what it is, dude.
iPhone, I can't put my finger on it.
Sweat chicks buy expensive
bags. Yep. Same thing. Ooh,
yeah. Quality lasts forever.
If you write though, if you write a lot
and type a lot, they're the shittiest.
They're fucking keyboards
are dog shit.
The new ones that they're clearly
clickity clickity there's no travel,
they're just clickity clickity clickity
clickity and shit gets stuck in them.
And they're trying to
figure out how to fix.
Mostly this part doesn't
work on my apple so I,
I've copied the space so whenever
I right after not comfortable
both for typing on like the whole like
how much fucking thinner doesn't have to
be Jesus Christ.
I know you guys are trying to make
them thin but make them so they're
comfortable to type on it does
make it thicker. Like just make it,
it doesn't have to be
that thin male. Yeah.
Big Old Gray keyboard is
the most comfortable thing.
The old school thing that we love,
but I think it's because we
learned how to type on that.
No, it's because they're mechanical.
Your fingers feel the tactile
sensation of pushing in those springs.
So it was like click, click, click,
click could cook your fingers.
Know where the keys are. When
you don't get into any feedback,
you make a lot of errors.
Like it's not as easy.
It takes a long time to get accustomed
to that short travel keyboard that you
get on those really thin Mac
books. I have a 2015 mac book.
I went and got an old one refurbished
because I hate the fucking new keyboard.
It's like I don't know what I'm touching.
Yeah, it's not, it's not moving.
It's so, so shallow. But apparently
they gotta fix that dude.
I have an IBM or not an
IBM and Lenovo thinkpad.
That thing is like the old IBM think pads
with Lenovo bought the company and now
they make them, they, you feel the keys.
It's like as you're typing, you know,
they have like 1.5 millimeters
of travel, which was like,
I bet you the next time I call
bet I'm going to, me and Joe,
we're gonna have a uh, typing
competition. I think I could,
I have none big no mistakes.
And the new apple, it's fine.
I think once you're used to it,
you're used to it. How did you,
you need to let yourself
go to the new technology,
both of them. But I liked the typing way
better on the Lenovo. It's just theirs.
This is not like just me.
This is a big thing that people who write
a lot say is that you want something
that has a lot of key
travel because 1.5 you know,
preferably maybe even 1.8
millimeter or something like that.
When you're doing that, you you get a
real good feel of where the keys are.
You don't, you also feel
like you've hit the bar,
you know you've hit the button,
you say see this feedback
and you don't think about,
what I find is that I'm
writing on one of those things.
I don't think about the keys as much as
I just am concentrating on writing where
I was like, oh, otherwise
I'm like, oh, did that,
that little extra thing where
you gotta look down. Oh,
I fucked up and I hit
that instead of that.
That doesn't happen as
much [inaudible] way less
you guys washing your keyboards because
I feel bad every time my son touches my
computer and it's probably keeping
them healthy. Dude, it's funny.
There's so much fucking bacteria on that
computer for cover and they use that
dust blasts thing is great. I
don't use any of that. Just blown.
Come right in your circuit board. Gross
your fucking kitchen tables. Gross.
Everything's gross. I know.
Do you think about like homeless
people touching guardrails?
It's like you go and touch that like
Ah, homeless people. The subway,
the subway rails must be just, oh,
it's brutal. The amount of times I've,
I've done this in New York City, like
I'll be going to put my hand on the hand.
I just don't touch handrails anymore
and I make sure that my son does and,
but I've just been putting my hand on
the rail and then I just pick up a bugger
like a human booger and I'm
like, okay, that's my week.
The story just ruined my hour.
[inaudible] and then it gets stuck
in your thumb. You flick it again.
It get stuck on that finger. Something
about other dudes boogers. It's really,
there's no way that that would end
my day. And your own kids booger.
I'll pick my son's nose in a
heartbeat. It's just a random stuff.
That's your own son. I mean
he's six now. You should stop,
but definitely stop picking his nose.
How old is it when you'd
be really concerned if your
son is still sucking their
thumb? Nobody. You're saying
shit, I wanted to deck wait
thumb anymore until you
confirm and they go, okay,
well now I know my son never
sucked his thumb. So yeah,
like if you had a kid though,
if he had a boy, I have a girl.
If you should never stop. She loves
second thumb. You don't have any kids.
I got an eight month old. Oh, you do?
[inaudible] last time I saw you were out
there breeding. I am. Congratulations.
Now you become even more libertarian,
correct? Yeah, but not with her.
I'm going to throw this carry. I'm with
my baby. I make the decisions there.
That's a good move.
Don't let babies call the shots now
that'll be just sugar and guns, but I'm
teaching a baby how to shoot a gun. Let
if a baby could actively shoot a gun,
like you know how much of a fucking giant
problem that would be like if a baby
was just like, dude, dude, now I'm feeling
like I'm not enough of a libertarian.
Yeah, because here's a gun.
Go homestead some land.
Their body can't really hold a gun and
shoot it. Right. It would go flying.
There's no way. But if they could,
do you know how what a great time they
would think it would be to shoot fucking
baby and you let it gotten just like,
dude, dude, dude. Right. They love it.
That projectiles, my son has, there's
nerf guns. That's how I know he's not gay.
He loves to shoot things and the lot
of gay people that shoot things now,
that's how I know he's not good. Like
he kept shooting his friend in the face.
The other guy you think about bears and
then he was talking the bullets in his
book.
If you had a bunch of bears that you
couldn't take them out to like a shotgun
range and shoot clay pigeons like 15
minutes before they started fucking each
other. Yeah. Eventually.
Oh my God, this shit.
But this kind of gave me
some warning. The guys,
they're just guys with like
guys, they got the wacky winery,
the gay kids that I grew, I'm sure. Yes,
there are gay guys who like to do doodly.
Dude things, right? Oh definitely.
But doodly do you know, not often.
I mean the how many gay
friends you have, they're like,
we should really go shooting
guns right now. Let's go hunt.
I bet there's a bunch of shop and that's
fine. They do. They want to do them.
But isn't it like girls? Like there's
girls that are like Woodsy, girls,
girls want to live in the woods and
shit. Yeah. I think these are exceptions.
If you're a gay like mountainy
guy and you're another mountain,
he guy's probably going to have
an all right life. That's all.
So also pretty hot. Gay
mountainy guys alone.
Just fucking Bolton down the door before
they bought Fox looking out to issue.
Yeah, sure. The neighbors don't know why.
So are you fell as brothers and
sisters or what? Brother and brother,
what's going on?
And they wrote a seasonal marina and
then they just suck and fuck in the off
season. Yeah. You go down the road
where those two homos live, Z , homos,
there's a couple of what it is as a couple
of dudes living in the oil efficient
house, don't get me wrong.
Great guys, great guys.
All they do is chop with them, but fuck,
that was the Bagel boss guy
when he said that. He goes,
I got a problem with gay people. He
goes, just don't touch me, you know,
especially in the private area.
Then we'll have the problem. I go,
is that what your life's worried about?
You don't want to hang out with
[inaudible] I property is going to start
grabbing viciously at your
Dick. Do you think that guy's a,
he's going to stick in there.
You think he's going to be uh,
like Joe the plumber or do you think
it's going to have some legs to him? No,
I think this is going to, Lenny Dykstra
is going to knock him out unconsciously.
He's five, 10. He's a
former, I know. He's like,
he ain't got alcohol problems and
shit, but he's got those big hands.
I see the videos getting arrested.
The other day he's going to
hit the Bagel boss. He left.
She was fighting Bagel boss boxing. No,
it's terrible. It's like she
was, you know, older now,
but I mean he's Lenny Dykstra. He's a
lunatic. He's only 55 so I'm like that.
He looks like 70 but he's, he's
still a fucking stocky dude, man.
Like four foot eight.
He's, I mean five was,
he fell, he's four. He's
really small. [inaudible]
down. You've seen that guy. I've
seen. He went to one of, uh,
someone's MMA gym and he was hanging
out with a bunch of fighters and he's
throwing punches and dancing around the
ring. I think. I want to say Matt Serra,
was it Matt Serra? Chris Weidman.
He was long island guy. Yeah.
So he was out there.
It's like, he's not like,
he doesn't have a
background in martial arts.
Like you could tell
that really fight shape.
Its probably shape and he's a tiny
little fellow by like a butterfly.
Sting like a butterfly.
There's, yeah, there's no good,
there's no learning how to fight, getting
in shape, doing it all like it. Yeah.
He's too small. It looks like he's
been in a bunch of fist fights.
He used to be arrested language
jacked at a point in his life.
I mean like shredded and you're losing
that strength. You're not going leave.
Even if he's out of shape. Even if
he's still a strong like Boltsy Guy,
I'm sure even conversation is going to
kill him because he was saying they heavy
play heavy on Lenny. Push it off.
Lenny Dykstra crazy. He was fucking
pro. I think there's no way.
There's no integrity in
celebrity boxing though.
I don't know if you could bet like a
zillion dollars. The top, yeah, Tim now,
so he's only 55 that's crazy.
Now he's her. That isn't,
he is. It'd be a little
bit older. He's older.
I just looked it up the other day. He's
not that old. He was a legit wild man.
Yeah. When he was at right there.
He looks like Mike. I can. Yeah,
he was fucking, that guy was a
legit wild man. Look at that.
Lenny Dykstra indicted for drugs,
threats, falling arrest in May. Who? Yeah,
he's winning. This fight is Uber driver.
He was high on ecstasy and coke and got
into an argument with his Uber driver
and then threatened his life when
the cops come. Yeah, the cop. Yeah.
The cops come and they're like, yeah.
This guy's saying, his fear for his life.
He's like, well, for me it's the base,
please. So innocent. It's hilarious. Oh,
that's funny.
And then they start checking his bag and
he starts freaking out about them going
through his bag. 56 yeah. Wow. Wow.
I thought he was older than that.
Even these days, living them hard
years, son ahead of celebrity fight.
Lenny Dykstra, it says, Bagel boss has
one inch penis. That was shit outrageous.
Click on that, please.
[inaudible] click this.
So rude. The world we live in,
Lenny Dykstra went on
Howard stern and did like a,
he said like he had girls come on to
say how good he pussy and they were like
swearing down. There we
are. Then it was a comic.
So he brought comedians from La and then
the community immediately just used it
for like a credit and that's
just a bumped as whole thing.
So he flew them in for
nothing. Oh, that's funny.
It's a crazy that he's going to hit
that little guy because that's so,
so wrong. I guess the Little Guy, I
wonder if he is going to down quick. Yeah.
I in celebrity boxing it doesn't usually
get too brutal. I think, you know,
I think what's his hunch
him once and it might kill
[inaudible] Bonaduce used to go for it
though. Headgear doesn't help you at all.
Head gear sometimes makes it worse
because you got all this extra weight and
your head snaps more like you
can get if you get head gear on,
that's more shit that you have to control.
Like one of the things about having a
strong knack is when you get punched you
can kind of control your head from moving
around too much and some guys can take
it better. But if you have a head gear on,
it's like extra weight and your brain
sloshes around inside your head.
I made it protects you from
cuts more than anything. This,
there's an argument that it would protect
you from cuts but the protecting it
from the thud cause it's not, it's
the fucking rocking of your brain.
You know, like it's in some ways
it's, it's a real mixed bag.
In some ways it's better to have had
gear on cause there's a little more
cushioning. But in other ways
like it's [inaudible] it makes me
[inaudible] cause I was surprised you
did that but you're like it just fucked.
I didn't want to fight with the head guy.
Tried to change it at the end because I
started sparring with it and it fucking
sucks. Dick did, you can't
breathe. Can't see that good.
You can't see when you start grappling
you start feeling like you're being
smothered right away no matter what.
As soon as they touch your head you feel
like the starts moving up in your face.
So I tried to get them to take it off
and they wouldn't and then my head gear
broke like in the first minute of the
fight and they were like, all right,
fuck you take it off.
Cause it was a shit show.
So we both took off our head gear and I
was like, Huh, where's the rules? Yeah,
head care's a tricky thing. You know,
it's like they think that
about football helmets too,
that they would actually be a safer
game if they couldn't clash heads with a
helmet on that they wouldn't do
it. They wouldn't play like that.
That's just not true.
Them clashing skulls,
just not safer to match it.
But the idea is that the only reason why
they played that way is because of the
helmets in the foot shoulder
gear. If you took that stuff away,
they wouldn't play like that.
Yeah. Back in the day they had,
they barely had any pads and you know,
thirties or forties or whatever when
they were playing with those little tiny
helmets, that game, if
you were an outsider,
like if you didn't know how big it was,
like if you didn't understand anything
about the cultural significance of
football and they showed you all the
brain damage and they showed you what it
is, he'd be like, Oh yeah, make that
illegal. Yeah, probably. If anything,
it should be illegal. Stop doing that.
Kids constantly run into each other
and they'll smash heads. That's crazy.
[inaudible] defensive offensive line.
Just the idea that it's
the funniest thing.
Susie say go just clunk heads
with another human beings.
We want it to be illegal and it's fun
thing to watch and it's a great way for
some guys to make a fuck load of money
and weigh the risks versus the rules.
Yeah.
But then a bunch of middle schoolers
are snapping their necks and my kid will
never play football.
[inaudible] get stopped.
They could then they could illegalize
MMA with that justification.
I don't want that to happen because we
punching and kicking is so inherently
violent. That's what we see it as being
this violent act, right? That it's,
we go, oh shit fighting. That's like
crazy. That's the most violent sport,
but it's so much less of a dangerous
sport than football. Football.
These guys are just running head first
at each other and every one of them,
every one of them has major, major issue.
You also get blindsided in football.
You know,
you'll have your eye on someone and
then you get head to head taken out from
someone else. That doesn't
happen as much in MMA,
but I mean when people get like
head kicked, knocked unconscious,
that's not good for your brain.
[inaudible] players being concussed,
just like just smashed each at time. Yeah.
And then they get up and they just
do it again and again and again.
They're a little bit stricter I think
on like if you get a concussion,
they won't put you back in. At least the
way they used to like when I was a kid.
But it's still fighters. We're getting
concussed once every, if you know,
once a year, if, if they're getting
knocked out once a year. I mean, you know,
but there's a also sub-concussive trial.
It seems to be the problem with CTE.
It's not just the knockouts,
it's just the thumps over and over again
over and over and over and training,
sparring, you know these guys.
So that's the real problem.
That's why also soccer players are getting
it and soccer players are starting to
get CT. What's worse?
Like getting like a Conor McGregor one
punch knockout or fighting Nick Diaz and
just getting like [inaudible]
for five rounds probably.
You're probably better off getting one
punch better than hey you probably up
better off getting dropped.
Getting beat up by Nick Diaz
for 15,000 to suck wasn't, this
wasn't the initial argument about MMA
being safer than boxing is that it's not
so much. So, you know,
with the gloves being bigger
in boxing and all that stuff,
that's actually worse cause you're gonna
keep taking too many shots count as
well. You can get knocked down
and then get up and go right.
You're be concussed and like, right.
Keep on fighting. Um, where's in MMA?
They'll stop it if you, if
you're not defending yourself.
So that's probably
definitely better. Yeah.
The thing about eight
counts and 10 counseling,
the people who've gotten off the
deck and had amazing performances,
so you'd ever want to stop it.
Like, look at Tyson fury gets off
the deck twice against Deontay wilder and
MMA. That fight would've been stopped.
Right. So it's like one of those,
particularly the last
round when he dropped him,
he would've definitely punched him a few
times and he would have been out cold
cause he was flat on his back. Um,
in MMA that would be the end
of the fight. And we are lucky.
It wasn't cause he got up like a fucking
superhero and even won the rest of the
round. He outbox him for
the rest of the round.
You survived the initial barrage and then
started catching him as he was coming
in and as Deontay was being reckless,
he caught him one time like stung
him and you're like holy shit,
he's winning this round now that he's
winning the rest of the round after
getting almost obliterated. So there's
an argument that that's better,
that crazy thing, entertainment value.
But the crazy thing from the CTE like
perspective about boxing to me is that
your people will get hit and then
they get hit and grab someone.
Cause that's just everyone's instinct
and they grabbed them and then you have a
little [inaudible] no, no, no,
no, no. Keep, keep punching.
Like don't do anything to avoid from
it. No, no, no, no. Step it back out.
And then they do that in
MMA, you'll see a lot,
someone get hit and then you know,
they get into a clinch and you get a few
minutes in a clinch where they're kind
of like, okay, I'm not taking
all the damage right now.
But the smart thing about that is
that's how you're supposed to fight.
Like you're giving people options to
defend themselves. It shouldn't be,
you can't defend yourself
other than punching back.
That seems seems kind of crazy. Like,
but I could grab them and just
stop these punches. No, no, no.
Against the rules. And what
kind of rules do we have?
Like you can only beat me up if I let
you beat me. That was one of the points.
[inaudible] dance around for an half
hour. But do you remember the original,
there was like Gracie videos that
they'd make an early UFC inaction.
And what they used to say all
the time was, and it's so true,
it was so interesting, is that if
two boxers just have a street fight,
they're going into a clinch and it's
probably going to end up on the ground at
some points.
I'm playing because the ref has this
break up a clinch over and over and over
again to make boxing
happen. Like even when,
even when you're a professional boxer
and you don't know anything about
wrestling or grappling,
you still end up grabbing the other guy
cause that's just like the only time
that doesn't take places.
When one guy knows how to strike
and the other guy doesn't.
And you see a lot of those videos online
where two dudes decided to get into
some sort of a street altercation and
one guy actually he's like a boxer and co
and he catches the guy and the guy falls
and bounces his head off the concrete
out called. There's a bunch of those
things that's bad. That's different.
So the thing about the Gracie Jujitsu
is like you got to always be aware of
this. People like that out there. There's,
there's always guys who can punch you
in the face and if they know how to
wrestle too and they can keep you away
and just keep punching you in the face,
you better know how to take
them down. You're still no dude.
Fuck the 2019 you have
[inaudible] people, Shit,
you got to look at their ears. You
got to look for the little signs,
like look in their eyes
[inaudible] next to infuse it.
Skinny necks aren't getting choked as
far as like skill like definitely, yeah.
You don't know weird time for fighting.
You know it's like, and we, we both,
I like both kinds. I like
just stand up only fights.
I like watching those and I like mixed
martial arts fights but I think like a
tans Crawford's coming on next. And I
think watching someone like him box,
like when you see the skill level
that that guy has switching stances,
doing all kinds of befuddling
people getting their range,
figuring them out and then just
teeing them up with perfect timing.
Like that's almost only
possible that kind of artistry.
If there's no wrestling right, there's
no leg kicks. If there's only the boxing,
that's the only way
you see that like that,
that kind of like beautiful comedy cause
otherwise you would do other shit too.
You would leg kick, you would try to
take them down. And that, so like the,
the level of dominance that
are real Floyd Mayweather,
a real world champion
boxer has with their hands.
It's hard to really appreciate
until you see it live. And you know,
like what you're seeing.
Like if you're in the building with
a guy always beating somebody up when
they're sparring, it's
like, oh, like this is,
you guys are playing two totally
different games by boxing. It's like,
I literally look at boxing as like very
much a sport and I think MMA is the
closest thing that we have.
Two competitive fighting 100% that's
sort of like the difference. It's,
you know, all things considered,
it's still not fighting.
You can't grab somebody's fucking balls
and Yank him off their bodies to bite
their nose. I know. [inaudible]
the Joe son who good got a,
you couldn't buy it and you couldn't, I
gouge, hit him with a fucking trash can.
Lid. We can't, we can't
fish hook and then,
but you used to be able to punch the
balls. There was a fucking great video of
Keith Hackney Fighting
Joe Song. Joe Sohn got up,
got him in a headlock and Keke fat
and he's just hammering his deck.
I mean full bloods and hunches over and
over and you see like Joe sounds like
going into shock. He takes
a few of them and he's like,
I'm not letting go with this joke.
[inaudible] fourth, Fifth Dick Punch.
It's like this is all over man over.
He was a drained head. Was it chemo?
Was He head budding hoists? Crazy. Yeah.
Yeah. Dude, that was fucking brutal.
Brutal. There was a lot of
head button back in the days.
It was an effective weapon and it
makes us like, oh, that's awful.
But small finger locks in
there. All these other bones.
How come you're allowed to hit with
these bones but you can't hit with that
bone. You also,
I would rather be headbutted by a guy
that I don't give a shit of what there's
no, there's not much
technique and headbutting.
I would rather be headbutted then be head
kicked by a dude who knows how to head
kick. You think there's no
tech, but there really is.
There's guys that spar and they fight and
left way and left the way is a type of
uh, Moitai where they put
ropes, uh, over their knuckles.
That's the only thing they have.
And they're allowed to head butt
and it's some wild ass shit.
And they do headbutt combinations on
the pad. Like they'll do tap, tap bang.
They'll like use their
head and train it. Wow.
Learn how TV and find
that left way. W E I t l.
U. T. H. D, You know, does commentary for
it is our friend Robin Black. He does,
uh, he does commentary for the left way,
but this is a brutal form of [inaudible]
where you're allowed to head butt cause
they already elbow. And I think,
you know, they're thinking, well,
if I can need and find any
content, I can do all these things.
Why can't I head button? It's right
there. He's fucking faces right
there. Ah, well you remember what,
uh, what Mark Coleman used to do?
Like he got a full year of season
before the headbutts were illegal.
Do. And he would, he would
smash people with the headbutts.
So here we'll be this
dude with this combination
[inaudible] so this is a Robin,
Robin black breakdown when he, he
goes, this dude goes off to the side,
pushes the dude's head away and then
immediately comes in with a perfect head
button. Boom.
It just slamming him in the face on
purpose with the top of his head.
So he's trying to hit like his eyes
and his nose and the soft tissue.
He's trying to hit that with
the hard part of his forehead.
Yeah. I think they do a lot
more damage than a fist.
But he only works one out
of every thousand times.
Lynn. No, no, no, no. This dot guy does
it a lot and if you do it this way,
the way he's doing it,
you taking a really hard part of your
forehead and you're smashing against a
soft part of the eyes and the nose.
This part of your forehead
is hard as fuck man.
Most guys who break their hand
and fights break their hands
top of the head. Yeah. Especially boxing.
The Tila Tequila reality show is two guys
were fighting over and that was like a
reality show that, oh, he
broke his chin, opened a thing,
and like it's separates his teeth.
He takes the head butts to the mouth.
It's a spitting out. The
blood's not turning. Uh,
you ever see someone get covered? The
blood's not turning red yet. It's black.
Black. He was like, yeah, he's playing.
What happens is his jaw splits down the
middle where you literally see his teeth
separate because it's
cracks in half like that.
It's the most horrific thing I've
ever seen. This VH1, by the way,
I saw that video. Whole classics. Talk
about it. A woman's fight. Really? Yeah.
Yeah. It was a Randy couture, his
wife Kim coture. Oh yeah. She fought,
she got her job broken and
it was separated and she
went out and fought the next
round with the jaw
separate touch, a Predator,
the the asshole inside and inside.
He was moving around and then she had
to get it wired up and fixed after the
fight was crazy. In the
sixth grade. Uh, he was,
he got into a fist fight with this
other kid and this other kid had brass
knuckles and Breslin was a wreck.
You'd buy him at like the mall
when I was a kid. Martial arts shy.
You'd give get like butterfly
knives. Nunchucks flying stars. Yeah.
Brass sounded like you could just go in
and start 12th and by deadly weapons.
Yeah man. They,
those little stores that would sell
nunchucks the size all the time.
Number two buttons.
So this kid had brass knuckles and he
fucking drilled this kid in the face and
broke his jaw. And for the whole
school year, like half school year,
he had to have a wire jaw
who should drinking chocolate
milk at lunch every day.
What happened? They can't even
tell the story. [inaudible]
punched him. He was a kid.
So it wasn't like Juvie or anything
that it was just like he got in trouble,
but that's it. Now you got
arrested? No, no. Didn't get it.
Didn't get arrested to go to
school together after that,
remove the brass copper kid from
the school. Didn't happen at school.
It happened to add a school. I
don't think that the kid who did it,
I know the who did. I don't think
he went to the same school, man.
Sorry for hitting you with brass
knuckles. The math homework, dude,
that's who's cool. That's
just, but that's terrifying.
That's where it's like you just don't
want to fuck with people like, well,
kids would get beat up
at home too. The kids,
the kids who get beat up by their
parents, they're ready to beat people up.
Of course be, it's becomes a
part of your, your everyday life.
You're mad at people,
you hit them mad at people that are
smaller than you didn't get away with it.
You hit him. Yeah. I don't think
people talk about that enough.
They talk about all the violence in the
world and nobody's talking about the
fact that since kids are toddlers,
they're being hit by the people that are
supposed to protect the most and that
fucks them up psychologically and it
does something to them. It's awful.
And it's a cycle, right?
You hit your kids because your dad hit
you and that's what made you the man that
you are today. That kind of horseshoe.
But it's so weird that it's the only
relationship where if you bring up this
topic, people will justify headache.
It's the only like no one will publicly
justify hitting their chick or hitting
their grandfather, taking personally.
Like you're attacking their parents.
They take it like they know, like my
mom's not a bad, my mom's a good mom. She,
you know, I deserved it. They'll tell
you that I deserved it. It's crazy.
Isn't it so weird that if anyone,
if you said publicly like, uh,
you know that you give your girlfriend
a slap, if she acts the wrong way,
everyone would universally be
like, that is just pure evil.
But if you say the same thing to
my two year old, my three year old,
everyone's just kinda like, whoa.
And then even I would do like conventional
questions, daughter, if you say,
if you grow, if my man talks too
much shit, I smack him in his face.
Girls would be like, you go girl. Sure.
Yes, that's true. But I also don't care.
That's like love on the fucking know.
But that's because the power dynamic
is the opposite. Right. You know,
like you're talking about the,
I'm not dating Cyborg. You may
[inaudible] give a shit. That's a serious
problem. If you're dating sideboard,
she's hitting me. Whatever her hands
are, the fucking real issue we, we catch.
She's gone. Huh? Out of the UFC
man, they fucked up. That sucks.
They made a video where it made it look
like Dana White was saying that they
just docked a added words that he
didn't say that was stupid. So dumb.
Do you think it was malicious or do think
it was a legitimate mistake in terms
of translating? There's no way it
could be anything other than stupid.
Whoever purpose, if it was done on
purpose. So it was just a stupid idea.
That's all it is. And it's really this
timing, whatever it is, whoever did it,
it just, that's just a
terrible error and it's,
it's really bad timing cause she
was almost uncomfortable last year,
but now Amanda Nunez came and kind of
took that juice and now it's like she's
damaged goods if she decides to
leave EOC without a Nunez rematch,
she beats Nunez. She gets
it all back, you know.
But she still say enough about the
star. She's, she'd go to one FC,
she'd go to bell tour,
she'd go to a lot of places and she'd
still be welcomed with open arms. She's,
she's a walked down the street and
get to huge pop star. Like, like she,
she shows up at those weigh in
shows and like the crowd flock star.
I remember just thinking that about
her. I saw her one time and there was,
I forget what this garden show and just
sat in like the front row of the UFC at
the garden and the place was like you,
you're so excited for just like turning
around and waving or because she was the
first like female terminator.
Yeah, Gina Carano.
And that was the bell
watching her beat up.
Gina Carano gives me
nightmares to this day.
It's crazy fight and the end of it when
there's a photo that we played on this
podcast before of her
sideboards hand palming gene has had
with black fingernails and she's punching
her in the face at the same
time. She's holding her head,
slamming her fist in the face.
You're like, I want out Jana.
Gina was queen when it was like
three minute rounds. They're like,
we all fought three minute rounds back
then for women. Yeah. Was half tops also.
You know, she was taking some stuff,
you know? For sure. For sure. Yeah,
for sure. That this,
that's part of the issue in [inaudible]
positive for some stuff. It's a,
you know, that's part of what
it is. It's part of what it is.
The build up to the Gina Carano fight
was when she choked out the news guy,
right? That was kind of viral was her.
I got news guy being like to put her
in like a rear naked choke and she had
choked him unconscious. It comes back to,
it's like very uncomfortable and
weird shrubs don't want to do it.
And then he was like, you could
see you could do it, it's fine.
And then he just looks like he was like,
it was one of those bands on gas for,
you'd get up and and make noises believe
that they're really gonna go out like
that. They don't believe they're
going to go out so quick. Yeah.
In the sixth grade we used to do the
thing where we would hyper Glendale game.
Yeah.
So you bend over and you just breathe
really heavy for like a minute, as hard,
as hard as you can. And then
when you come up really fast,
you're already light-headed. And
then your friend puts his hands,
his palms and your carotid arteries
and just presses kinda light.
And then within three seconds you
just slide down the wall. Whoa.
It was my first time
I ever got high. Yeah.
But your friends will let you fall
and hit your fucking head. Yeah. No,
you fall, bounce your hook and head
off a curve. You gotta catch him.
I gotta knock him out. I got to get Jim.
I don't think that's
necessarily that bad for you,
but it's definitely not good for you,
especially when your [inaudible]. Yeah.
11 developing your brown
probably shouldn't do it.
Don't be choking out, but
it's a, it happens all the
time in the gym and no one,
no one stops that. They
get choked unconscious.
They wake up and they go back
to rolling again and they,
the way they talk about it
like it's a garden hose,
the garden hose shuts off the power
to the brain. Then everything's fine,
but I'm like, man, you ain't a doctor.
God knows how to choke people.
Show me some long term studies on dudes
who've been choked unconscious multiple
times. Show me a doctor making
garden hose analogy. Call me a bitch.
I'll tap quick. I'm not going
unconscious, man. Stop. That's silly.
I don't want it. Yeah, I'd
go an unconscious thing.
Who knows what that's doing?
You're going into the Netherlands.
He might come back a totally different
person. Totally different. Life.
Should have been a hundred years. You
come back with a false memory of the past.
Totally new dementia. Lived a hundred
lives since then since I was knocked out.
Dad had that happens to guys because
when they get hit and knocked out, when
they come to,
they do not know what happened and they
have to be reminded over and over and
over again. Uh, I mean it must feel like
you woke up and you have the dimension,
like it must feel surreal.
[inaudible] told me a story
after the Dan Anderson fight.
He literally had no idea what happened.
It was like he had no idea where
he was. He didn't even thought he,
he thought his fight was a few weeks
out still. Yeah, that's what it was.
Scary Shit Ben asking.
We're saying he has no memory of like
anything in the arena. After that,
Dan was one of the worst. That's what
I was [inaudible] out of the arena.
So slow. That was one of the
worst knockouts of all time.
The amount of power that your flying
knee has when you're ducking into it is
accentuated because he's going in for
the take down and he's got a strong take
down. Right.
So he's going in with everything he has
face first and [inaudible] running at
him. Oh my God. It's the hurt.
That's the biggest impact I think on
sports ever seen as we're talking about
football players crushing other.
That's the moment of impact.
What were the dangerous thing about two
football players crashing their bodies
into each other. It's exactly that.
And they are super athletes creating
that momentum. I mean, yes, it's nuts.
How crazy is it to be undefeated?
Never to lose to anybody.
And then that's your one.
Your one blemish is like
the biggest nonsense.
So much shit that it sucks cause I like
Bam. I'm a big fan. He's really funny.
I then too,
he talks so much shit and when you talk
shit like that and then you fucking
Louis, he's got it. He's
got to eat those words. No,
he's marketed himself amazingly.
And then that's part of the marketing
himself is like he has his own down-home
version talking shit. You know,
like even as boom roasted thing.
Like you could tell it's like he's almost
kind of playing a doofus character,
but he's a very smart guy.
Like I had him on the podcast and he
sends me book recommendations and Shit.
He's like a really well read,
interesting guy. He just,
that's his character and his in his part
of his strategy is to know the fuck out
of you. But when you flatlined
him like that, after a note,
him annoying the fuck out of, you know
what's that word? Shodan fraud hasn't,
what does that word? Just desserts.
What does that call did? I don't know.
Something like the [inaudible] the
pleasure that you feel from someone else's
obvious demise, right? Is
that how that sounds right?
Is that pleasure derived from another
person's misfortune and there you go.
That's what it is. Because with that it's
like, it's almost like in a weird way,
that's what he was trying to get
mouse but all to do like go crazy.
So the takedowns are there, but if
it doesn't work out it goes very bad.
Well Mossville doll just took that
chance with that flying knee entry and he
practiced it over and over and over
again and he kind of knew what the way he
circled. See the,
we circled the circle off to the side
and then came out on that way. We'll see.
We knew he would go at him with feeding
into him that way and so it perfectly
taught cause he was
coming down from the side.
He knew he was going to lean in that
way, but he also mounts with all said,
he was like,
I w I was real confident if he took
me down I was going to get back up.
And that does kind of demonstrate that
like if you're a real concerned about the
takedown, you're probably not going to
open with sprinting into a flying name,
which is one it goes.
Mazda doll is not even a dude who is known
for being this unbelievable wrestler.
But first time I saw Mazda doll was an
old school Kimbo slice a Miami backyard
fighting video. Yeah,
he did those dude [inaudible] he
came out and he fought this guy,
I think his name was big ray and was guy
was like 230 pounds and it was George
and it was like 180 pounds. And
he can not just boxes dude up.
And it was so bad. Like all
the kids were followers,
like chickens running around the
backyard. It was so hardcore.
And then he ends up being a,
someone to I think Strikeforce a few
years later is when I saw him in MMA and
uh, he's had a pretty crazy trajectory
to be where he's at right now.
He is right on the cusp of being, you
know, if he, if he give him the title,
he'll be one of the
biggest stars in the sport.
He's one of the best motherfuckers
in the sport for sure.
There's no doubt about it with
everything. He's super well-rounded.
He can do everything. His
take down defense is amazing.
He's got some of the best hands
in the division period. I mean,
you look at him knocking out Darren till
with that leap in left hook. The way,
the way he did it, the way he set it up,
he landed it earlier and then he
landed again. He figured it out.
He figured out a spot with this guys open.
There's like this dip in what he
does. And he found that opening,
he's gotten better, right? Like he's
definitely like, he's decimal syndicated,
he's more dedicated, you know,
and now he wants a big payday and so
they're probably talking about doing that.
Nate Diaz, he'll get a big pay down
on that one. That's a big fight.
That fight will be huge. Isn't it?
Fucked up that it was one is the one
that I'm almost out of all of the guys
we're talking about, I'm least intrigued
to watch fight next. Oh Man, I'm not,
I fucking love watching that guy fight
cause he's got this marauding relentless
style that's very similar to Colbys
except he hits harder and he'll,
he'll try to take people out. Like
Colby Colby just keeps that heat on you.
Yeah. But Colby striking technique
might be a little bit better.
It doesn't hit quite as hard.
But the stuff he was showing
against Robbie Lawler,
those jabs and body kicks and stuff,
I mean that was pretty impressive.
So he's friends with my buddy cam
Hanes and they trained together and uh,
can't Cam's description
of him. He said, listen,
the guy talks all this crazy
shit. Right. He's doing it,
but he never stopped training.
He's just constantly training.
That's why he's got that insane cardio.
He knows that's as big as weapon.
His biggest weapon is he's like,
he's like, ready, keep up. Wait,
hey,
you got to try to keep up and he's fucking
going and going and going and going
and everybody wills.
That's why I'm so interested to see who
spawn fight cause he's gonna fight him
and Ooh, smog does the same thing to
people. That's what he did. I think Tyron,
I think there was issues with
Tyler and going into that fight.
He looks like a shell of
himself. It wasn't firing back,
but some of that you got to give credit
to Ou Swan, that fucking pressure,
that relentless pressure is striking,
which is just, he knows how to fight long.
He's got an incredible
fucking ground and pound game.
He's got real knockout power and Colby
did a similar thing to Robbie Lawler
where it kind of looked like,
why isn't he firing back?
Why isn't hit because he's caught, his
back's on the cage getting taken down.
He's getting jabbed constantly.
I never has a moment to just reset and
take a deep breath cause like he's just
on you. The whole fight guys didn't
use to fight that way. And I,
I talked to Colby about this,
we were talking about the principle of
like how like how hard do you do when you
punch in, how already punching.
He's like 70% so he just hit him with a
steady stream of 70% you never see him
bite down and fucking, you
never see that those would,
DC always likes to call big
actions, those big actions,
those cost a lot of energy and you've
got to figure out when to do those.
Maybe you're Francis and Ghana and
those big actions lead to ouster Overeem
getting knocked into the
Netherlands. But if not,
then you're going to blow out your gas.
Like we saw him with steep Emile church,
lifted them over the
head in the first round.
And how cool does that look that you're
holding this huge guy over your head and
dropping them.
But then after that you kind of just get
to take down and he gets back up to his
feet. And then by the fourth
round you're kind of wondering,
is that really good strategy
to be lifting these guys over?
[inaudible] paid when Steve Bay fought
Francis and Ghana. Oh, that one.
I managed to avoid the big actions of
in Ghana and then wear them out and then
take it down and beat him
up and retain the title.
The only guy that's been
able to survive in Ghana,
the DC fight is a hard one to watch man,
because he's the best guy in the world.
He's so nice. I love that guy to death,
so watching him get his body destroyed
because he kept digging those left hooks
the body. I was like, Ooh.
Part of me was like, damn,
that's a pretty powerful album. Those
fucking loud, but it's, it's, it wasn't,
it was the crispness of it. He was,
he was standing in front of him,
popping them and then sliding back and
he would just stick that fucking left
hook into the liver and he kept
hitting it. Part of me was like, man,
that is a beautiful left hook, nasty body
shots, but pardon me? He's like, damn,
DC, you got to get away from
that. You got to get outta there.
You got to take this guy
down. It's hard when you're,
when you really love a guy and you
watched him fight, it's hard. It's very,
very difficult to do commentary.
Just what's the pain on the,
on the liver punches.
What could that or what's the damage
that can do this shut shoe that makes you
like, I've seen people crumble on,
I'm going to hit you with one punch,
but show me on a little, you don't want
it. It's a horrible feeling where like,
like shocks your body, your body goes like
it's or show. How about that show Dave,
where to hit right here. It's right.
You're almost getting shocked. Like
electrical lower. If you, if you,
if someone is standing in front of
you and they hit you with a left hook,
most likely they'd be
hitting you in the liver.
And it's like right where these
floating ribs are tucked in.
And when you slam someone hard like right
around the low, you know, it was um,
one of the masters of it is Canelo
Alvarez show Canelo Alvarez body shots.
Like maybe there's a video we could
look, he's got a beautiful one.
We steps in and just fucking rips that
left hook to the liver and just your body
just goes d it just fucking shots down.
It's the weirdest feeling man.
It's like your legs stop working.
Everything stops working
your whole body. Just see
it looks like it didn't happen
to them until that last one. Um,
I think he was playing poker face.
[inaudible] Canelo is a
fucking master at this shit.
He would just dig this
thing, look at this. Whoa.
That one's only going the kid side
and that's going into the side.
But most of the time it's go into
the liver. Most of the time it,
well he's going to anything that's
open. Right. But that's the liver.
She's going for the liver against
Golovkin but Koloff Ken's got that lower,
that low guard with his right arm.
He's blocking it from happening.
The guy was coming up
next toxin. So much fun.
Like it's a fun sport to do. Well
when these kinds of guys are fighting,
when triple g and Canelo
are fighting like fuck.
It's like if you're a fan of the sport,
you've seen the highest
level two champions in their
prime going after it. It's,
it's amazing to watch,
but that punches a t like and getting
hit there is a terrible feeling.
And DC got hit there multiple times and
he was from like the second round on,
he was at, you were talking
about it when he was there,
but he was just putting his hands down
and kind of letting Steve Bay hit him as
hard, dangerous way to
fight steep Emile church.
Like I think he just wanted
to put pressure on him and
make steep a feel like he
didn't deserve to be in there with them.
I think maybe in that approach he
was, uh, trying to wear him out,
which keep the pressure on
them and make them discouraged.
Or maybe he had genuine
disdain for his abilities.
Maybe he really didn't think
too steep it could hurt him.
And he was just eventually
going to catch him.
And then there was a lot of people that
thought because of the way he knocks DP
out, maybe Steve Bay isn't as
durable as he used to be, right?
Because Steve Bay used to take
tremendous shots from everybody,
but then he got knocked out in one punch
by DC after taking tremendous shots in
the Ingando fight. So the
question would be like,
how much damage have they
taken that in Gando fight?
But then he came back and he ate
everything that DC had offer him.
He just kept beating him to kid to
take it on the Chin and eating it.
And eventually he started
taking over the fight.
And when he started ripping the body in
the fourth round, it was like, whoa. He,
it was perfect. I mean,
I've never seen anybody have better body
punches in a championship. That was,
that was the thing.
There was like a corner call or you
think he just like improvise and saw that
that was open and he knows how to
fight. He saw an opening. Everybody,
everybody knows. I mean that's
such a standard technique.
That's like a corner call. Someone's
throwing a leg kick. So it was working.
So yeah, it never got blocked.
Once he didn't have an answer,
it didn't have an answer to it. He
didn't duck it. He didn't block it.
He didn't, he didn't try to take him
down. He just Kinda got stuck stance.
The problem with those liver shots too
is they SAP your energy so bad and you,
you can't make a big move anymore.
So you have to kind of pretend like
everything's okay. And then Bam,
he hits you again and you're like,
oh shit, we're in trouble here.
But still you're looking like nothing's
wrong, but your gas tank is, fuck,
everything's on empty and you're
fucked. You really can't fire back.
That's why DC didn't fire back and he
kept getting shot to that body bang.
And every time bang, he gets shot
to that body. You see it in us.
And then Steve [inaudible] got him
against the cage and started uncorking
punches and DC just didn't have
anything. His body was shutting down,
didn't have anything in him to
stop that onslaught. I mean,
it's amazing that guy's the,
this deep is the most successful
heavyweight in the history of the sport.
And during the Cormier, whether he
fights again or not, he'll go down.
He's one of the greatest ever,
you know? But he also is,
what is he 42 it's 40 40 40 is that true?
I was 48 so that might be two.
It could be 42 yeah. You asked 42
when you look at like, you know,
do you see what he's done?
It's incredible. I mean,
and nobody else has ever done
that. It's just, it's Kinda,
it's probably hard to
convince him of that.
The big fight is the
Steve Bay fight, honestly,
because beating guys for the vacated
crown with enlight heavyweight is not the
same as beating Jon Jones.
But beating Steve pay is like being the
heavyweight version of Jon Jones. Yeah.
That's, that's the biggest
accomplishment ever.
And I'd liked him at heavyweight
because he wasn't getting drained.
But I just don't think that was, I
mean I don't think, I don't know,
maybe couldn't have
fought him any other way,
but I don't think that
was the best strategy,
the dropping of the hands and the
moving toward him with the stain,
but me maybe that would have worked on
some guys and maybe that has worked on
other guys like rumble Johnson
and worked on him. You know,
he mean he eventually puts that heat on
you and so many guys crack under that
heat. Do you want to see as a friend,
do you want to see him fight a third fight
that is entirely dependent upon where
his head's at? I mean if he, first of all,
I'm sure he's a very intelligent guy
with a lot of years of competition under
his belt, whether it's Olympics, PR, you
know, wrestling at the highest level,
whether it's UFC strike force before
that he's fought for a long time.
Nobody needs to tell him when
to make decisions when not.
He's emotional right now.
I'm sure he's going to take some time
off and he'll probably consult with his
family and probably figure
out what he wants to do.
But I bet if I had to guess
his competitive instincts
are going to tell him that
he could have at least one more fight
and that it would be a rematch with Steve
Bay because he was dominating the first
round and he let it get away from him
and he wasn't listening to
his corner, you know, crazy.
Bob Cook was yelling in his corner,
keep your damn hands up. You know,
he didn't like it. Bob Cook didn't
like it. He respected [inaudible].
He's a giant man. He's a fucking
big motherfucker. Big Long,
tall Croatian. And he's tough as shit man.
And I think because Daniel knocked him
out in the first round and the first
fight, you know, uh, he, he believed
he could knock 'em out again,
but Steve Bay could take a Goddamn
shot this time. You know, I mean, yeah.
You never know why a guy gets knocked
out that way with one punch. I mean,
it was a perfect punch for sure.
I mean, the way he threw it,
it was beautiful the way he
threw it from inside the clench.
It comes over the top of the shoulder
blam and lends that perfect punch,
that chaos. I mean it
was amazing. Yeah. But
it was also such a competitive fight
that I'm super intrigued to see a third
fight. You know, it's not like
it's not a foregone conclusion.
The CPA is going to be
able to do that again.
Daniel could be adjusted and
come out with a better game plan.
100% he could win that fight.
Um, and it's, in my opinion,
the best fighter heavyweight
competitively. I don't
think, I ain't gone,
it'd be a good fight, but I think the
CPA wants that. Again, I'm not convinced.
I mean I think in gone who
might be the next guy? I mean,
I think he might be the champ
for while he's definitely
got what it takes because he's got one
thing that 100% one punch knockout power,
100% not a fucking humans going to be
there if he full-on connects and smashes
one through your guard. Everyone
goes, night-night everyone,
100% of the humans that
have ever walked here,
if that guy punches you full blast,
but it's whether or not he's gonna
be able to do that to steep back.
We all thought he had a chance of
doing it the first time, but Steve,
I shut it down and you know,
maybe, maybe he's better now,
but maybe Steve Bay is going to come
into this fight even more energized ever
after beating DC and winning his
title back. I mean, maybe he's gonna.
Maybe he saw something from that
fight that if he had to do it again,
he would have implemented
really quickly. You know,
Deep Abd Dude, he did not
want to take another fight.
He was do whatever place he was in.
He was fucking in his firehouse list,
hit up his boots. Everybody's thinking
about getting that title back.
He does not want to lose that title again
for ignore. No Man was weird.
Everybody was so concentrated on the
Brock Lesnar idea that they were ignoring
them.
It was, it's weird because when
somebody said that the other day,
whatever publication was talking about
CBD being the greatest heavyweight of all
time, this is before the fight. Um,
I remember going like Izzy and then you
start listing off his credentials and
you realize that he has the most defenses.
He's also fought the most competitive, um,
titled Defensive as title
defenses as well. Um,
then u s it becomes a little more
apparent, but I kind of under,
I almost understand it
because even as the,
and I'm a pretty big fan of
the sport, but I remember just,
I wasn't like chomping at the
bit for the rematch for him.
It wasn't like I was like, oh I really
want to see that. Steepy damn corny.
I remember mentioned, I can't
even put my finger on why.
Oh I did. I wanted to see it bad.
I wanted to see real bad
cause I wanted to see,
and I liked the fact
it was 13 months later.
So I think it gave his body some time
to heal up. I think you fight in Ghana,
it's like getting hit by a
train. I mean, you might live
Michael
[inaudible] wine into a fucking tree and
come down a day later. What happened?
Like when DJ Jazzy Jeff will
get thrown out of the club.
Yeah, but I think he's,
if he keeps it together,
he's the next guy.
I mean he's the next guy
in line to be the champion.
I mean he has everything to lose his,
he has the championship to lose if it
steep bay retires. When Steve Bay's done,
Frances is the fucking man and maybe,
maybe Francis beats him in a rematch.
Who knows? Again, all
he has to do is connect.
He'd be a different guy in the rematch.
He would understand what it's like to go
five hard rounds with the guy who could
take you down and beat you up.
He would understand that his
wrestling has to be on point.
His Cardio has to be on point and there's
not going to be times where he can
100% unload and know for sure the guy's
not gonna be there because the guy
survived and he didn't have the gas
tank for the remaining four rounds.
And so this is going to be a new guy
that Steve Bay fights and he might very
well just play it smooth and just stay
on the outside and pick his shots.
And then when he gets him hurt
then uncork. I mean we don't know,
but we know Steve Bay might take
them down quicker this time.
Maybe CPA mid say fuck all this standup
dude, let's just wrestle. You know,
he just like come at him a couple,
pump a few jabs and shoot a fucking
double on him and take it down. Dude,
he took down D C Steve paid
took down d c that's giant.
The only other guy I've ever, who's
ever done that as John Jones and Steve,
I did it more emphatically, you know? I
mean it was pretty God damn impressive.
Well that's the other one
at uh, at heavyweight.
I want to see I before
John John's retires.
I want to see him play at heavyweight.
Yes. That's what I want to see.
Sean John's at 235 pounds. Fuck
yes. Steroids to the gills.
Graham's fallen on his ass.
Just fucking monster. Dude.
I would love to see if he could handle
steep a m or if Cormier one of that fight
I if day in court, me and John
Jones wanted to fight again,
I'd want to see that fight at heavyweight.
Well I guarantee you if John
Jones fights at heavyweight,
he'll probably be at just what he
walks around at because the word around
Jackson's was that he would wrestle
with heavyweights and just ranked all of
them. That he would throw
people around the gym.
I mean when I talked to Tate Fletcher
when he was down there and other guys who
trained with John when John was down
at Jackson's a as a light heavyweight
champion was just
ragdoll and heavyweights.
He's a phenomenally powerful
guy and you really saw them,
the Cormier fight like I think for me it
was shocked in that first fight of how
fucking strong John Is. I
mean he's a long thin guy,
but he is ridiculously strong and I
think as a heavyweight EBL fuck load to
handle for a lot of guys. I want
to say and I think he actually,
he has a star power too.
I think that puts the UFC on the map in
a weird way cause they haven't really
had the major star as
a heavyweight champion.
Like that fucking dude who is like
best in the world, pound for pound,
best as a heavyweight champion
as the heavyweight champion.
But if John could be [inaudible]
that would be that. Cause he's,
he's definitely the best pound for
pound fighter in the UFC right now.
Definitely. You look
at his accomplishments,
it's arguably he's the best
pound for pound fighter ever.
Cause he's really never lost that one.
Matt Hamill fight to try to reverse
that cause it was a bad decision.
It was a bad decision. Dude was a
bad decision. This is a bad decision.
There's disqualify. Yeah, make it a
no contest. So he's still undefeated.
That's what it really should have gone.
My only problem with it is it really
should be a victory. Crushed him. Oh yeah.
It was ridiculous. She doesn't
feel like it's a waste.
The thing is like the guy's never
really lost. So if you look at his,
his career, like who
the fuck can say that?
Who the fuck has fought like Leo
Machida, Rashad Evans, rampage Jackson,
the top of the food chain over and
over generations, three generations,
four different generations of the best
guys. Gustafson, everybody look at that.
There's actually a number like there,
the, that one loss on his record.
If you could really break it down.
There was some sort of like statistics
that could come in and really look at it.
There's a number,
an amount of money that he's lost
because he has that loss on his record.
Whether whatever, is it more
marketability? Maybe? Who
knows? There's something.
It definitely, there has to be some
things. Otherwise I have to go.
You do have to go to shit or wrap this
pitch up. All right gentlemen, thank you.
As always, you cucked out
again until now. That was good.
I was going to come in Bob face, they
wouldn't let me so we stopped it,
so I appreciate you guys.
I appreciate it. Gang fest.
I think it's awesome what you guys
are doing for comedy. I really do.
You're right. You're just going for
it and that's what we need more of.
We need more of people that are doing
real comedy, and you guys do it.
I appreciate the fuck out of it and I
support you at every turn. Oh, thanks.
[inaudible] the man. We really appreciate
it. Love you buddy. Bye fuckers.
That's fine.